Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Near this spot are deposited the remains of one who possessed beauty without vanity, strength without insolence, courage without ferocity, and all the virtues of man without his vices. This praise, which would be unmeaning flattery if inscribed over human ashes, is but a just tribute to the memory of Bosun, a dog, who was born in Newfoundland, May 1803, and died at Newstead, November the 18th, 1808.
感谢收听《历史余音》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。此处安息着一位集美貌与谦逊、力量与温和、勇敢与仁慈于一身的伟大存在，他拥有人类所有的美德而无其恶习。如果这段赞美刻在凡人的骨灰之上，便是毫无意义的谄谀；然而对于一只名叫博森（Bosun）的狗的记忆，这却是实至名归的敬意。它于1803年5月出生在纽芬兰，并于1808年11月18日在纽斯特德逝世。
So Tom Holland, those are the words written by Lord Byron's friend, John Cam Hobhouse, on the urn of the dog, Bosun and Newstead Abbey, aren't they? Very moving tribute. Tremendously moving. And Byron wrote something himself, didn't he, about this dog? Yeah, so um inscribed on this tomb which is in the grounds of newstead abbey byron's ancestral home you have an entire poem by byron uh which concludes with the splendid couplet to mark a friend's remains these stones arise i never knew but one and here he lies so man's best friend dominic And that's the theme of today's episode.
那么，汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland），这些文字是拜伦勋爵的朋友约翰·卡姆·霍布豪斯（John Cam Hobhouse）写在纽斯特德修道院的狗——博森的骨灰瓮上的，对吧？这是一份非常感人的致敬。极其感人。拜伦自己也写过关于这只狗的诗，对吧？是的，呃，刻在这个位于纽斯特德修道院（拜伦的祖宅）庭院里的墓碑上，有一首拜伦写的完整诗作，呃，它以一句精彩的对句结尾：“铭记挚友遗骸，此石拔地而起；我平生仅识一人，而他正长眠于此。”那么，人类最好的朋友，多米尼克，这就是今天节目的主题。
We've chosen the seven greatest dogs in history. The magnificent seven. So Tom, I'm delighted you've chosen this because this is your topic. And what surprises me is that you're more of a cat person yourself. No, I love dogs as well. Do you? Yeah, I do. But because I live in London, it's easier to have cats.
我们挑选了历史上最伟大的七只狗。壮丽七雄。所以，汤姆，我很高兴你选择了这个，因为这是你的领域。而让我感到惊讶的是，你自己其实更喜欢猫。不，我也很喜欢狗。是吗？对，我确实喜欢。但因为我住在伦敦，养猫更方便一些。
Of course. Otherwise, you have to kind of go around with bags, scooping up poo and it's all a bit horrid. I'm going to betray my, my hand here. I'm very much team dog. Dominic, you astound me. Yeah. I think if I were an animal, I probably would be a dog. Slightly rabid one, perhaps.
当然。否则你得带着袋子到处走，清理便便，这感觉有点糟糕。我要在这里表明我的立场了。我是坚定的爱狗派。多米尼克，你让我太震惊了。对。我想如果我是一只动物，我大概会是一只狗。也许是一只稍微有点狂犬病的狗。
Yeah. A stray. The kind of stray dog you might find on a Greek island. You'd be, you'd be a British bulldog, wouldn't you? Oh, that's kind. Actually, Bosun died of rabies. Did he? Which was very sad.
对。一只流浪狗。那种你在希腊小岛上可能会遇到的流浪狗。你会是一只英国斗牛犬，对吧？哦，这话说得真好。其实，博森是死于狂犬病。是吗？这非常令人难过。
And Byron cared nothing for the danger of getting it himself and tended it, wiped away the froth from Bosun's jaws. Oh, cranky. Very, very touching. So I think this is an episode that has lots of touching moments, but also some quite sinister moments as well. Yeah. So quite a lot of variety. There is one very famous dog who does not feature in this and i think it's because we have agreed that um we will do an entire episode
而且拜伦根本不在乎自己被传染的危险去照料它，擦掉博森嘴边的白沫。哦，天哪。非常、非常感人。所以我认为这期节目有很多感人的时刻，但也有一些相当阴暗的时刻。对。所以种类相当丰富。有一只非常著名的狗并没有出现在这里，我想这是因为我们已经同意，呃，我们会专门做一期节目。
on loka i hope i've pronounced that right is that your russian accent that's my russian accent the stray dog from moscow that was the first dog in space okay and i think that her story would be a wonderful way to um talk about the beginning of the space race and cosmonauts and all that kind of thing. So very good. She will come later. Well, our first dog is a contemporary of Laika's, I think. Yes.
关于莱卡（Laika），希望我发音准确。那是你的俄罗斯口音吗？那是我的俄罗斯口音。这只来自莫斯科的流浪狗是第一只进入太空的狗，好的，我认为她的故事将是一个极好的切入点，呃，来谈论太空竞赛的开端、宇航员以及诸如此类的事情。非常好。她稍后会出场。好吧，我们的第一只狗我想是莱卡的同时代者。是的。
Part of Laika's generation, in fact. I chose this specially for you. Yeah. So this is Chekaz, who's already featured on The Rest Is History. And Chekaz is the dog of Richard Nixon. Yeah. So very much a canine friend of the show, Checkers. So Checkers, Tom, do you know what kind of dog Checkers was?
事实上，是莱卡那一代的。我是专门为你挑选的这一只。对。这就是切克斯（Checkers），它已经登上过《历史余音》了。切克斯是理查德·尼克松的狗。对。所以切克斯可以说是本节目的忠实犬类朋友。那么，切克斯，汤姆，你知道切克斯是什么品种的狗吗？
She's Spaniel. That's right, Tom. That's right. And I can safely say people won't have noticed this listening to this podcast, but we actually had a massive hiatus then for about 10 minutes. We did more research than we've ever done before on the rest is history. Well, I frantically tried to work out whether Checkers was male or female because Nixon gives a famous speech about Chequers in which he consistently refers to Chequers as it. Which is very Nixon, isn't it?
她是西班牙猎犬。没错，汤姆。完全正确。我可以肯定地说，听这个播客的人不会注意到这一点，但我们当时其实暂停了大约10分钟。我们对《历史余音》做了有史以来最多的研究。嗯，我拼命地想弄清楚切克斯是公的还是母的，因为尼克松发表了一场关于切克斯的著名演讲，在演讲中他一直用“它”（it）来指代切克斯。这非常符合尼克松的风格，不是吗？
Very Nixon. But Chequers was a black and white caucus manual. It was she. The New York Times ran an obituary of Chequers in 1964 and said of her, she had a ferocious bark but a gentle disposition.
非常尼克松。但切克斯是一只黑白相间的可卡犬。它是母的。《纽约时报》在1964年发表了切克斯的讣告，并在其中评价它：“它有着凶猛的叫声，但性格温和。”
Very like Richard Nixon, actually, Tom. Do all the first dogs, so the presidential dog is obviously the first dog. Yeah. Do the first dogs normally get a bit traced in the New York Times? No, they don't. But Chequers is a genuinely important political dog. So to set the scene, we're in 1952.
汤姆，这其实非常像理查德·尼克松。所有的第一宠物狗——总统的狗显然就是第一宠物狗。对。第一宠物狗通常都会在《纽约时报》上留下痕迹吗？不，它们不会。但切克斯是一只真正具有重要政治意义的狗。为了还原背景，我们回到了1952年。
Senator Nixon, as he then was, had just been chosen by former General Dwight D. Eisenhower as his running mate on the Republican ticket. And Nixon was a slightly controversial choice because he was a bit of a Republican hatchet man, famous for his sort of attacks on communism and so on. And in September 1952, so just a couple of months before the presidential election,
当时的参议员尼克松刚刚被前将军德怀特·D·艾森豪威尔（Dwight D. Eisenhower）挑选为共和党总统候选人搭档。尼克松是一个颇具争议的人选，因为他有点像共和党内的“杀手”，以攻击共产主义等行为而闻名。而在1952年9月，也就是总统大选前几个月，
the newspapers ran this story that they said it was a private slush fund. So the New York Post said, secret rich men's trust fund keeps Nixon in style far beyond his means. Now, as people remember, if they listen to our Watergate podcast, Nixon was a man of very modest means, modest background, and was very conscious of it. And when he was elected senator from California, a group of donors in Southern California, so there's sort of the network that basically backed him into the Senate, they got together and they created a fund to meet his political expenses. Now, this was actually not that uncommon in those days. So you had a small expense account as a US senator.
各大报纸刊登了这样一则报道，称这是一个私人秘密 slush fund（政治黑金基金）。因此《纽约邮报》宣称：秘密富豪信托基金让尼克松过上了远超其经济能力的奢华生活。正如大家如果听过我们的水门事件播客所记得的那样，尼克松出身非常卑微，背景普通，并且对此极为敏感。当他当选加利福尼亚州参议员时，南加州的一群捐赠者——也就是基本上支持他进入参议院的那张网络——聚在一起，建立了一个基金来支付他的政治开支。其实，这在当时并不罕见。作为美国参议员，你确实有一笔少量的差旅费报销账户。
But if you're from California, there's a lot of flights back and forth. Washington, you're only covered for one, I think, a year. So this fund was going to meet his airmail and his travel costs and his telephone bills and sending out newsletters and stuff. And they raised about $18,000. So that's the equivalent to about 10 times that today. And because Nixon was a sort of very disputatious, pugnacious person, the revelation of this fund was a gift to his opponents. And they used it to sort of say he's very sleazy and he's corrupt. I think which was actually a bit
但如果你来自加利福尼亚，往返华盛顿的航班有很多，我想一年只报销一次。所以这个基金将用于支付他的航空邮件费、差旅费、电话费以及发送通讯等开支。他们筹集了大约18,000美元。这相当于今天的十倍左右。而且由于尼克松是一个非常好斗、争强好胜的人，这个基金的曝光简直是送给他政敌的一份大礼。他们利用这一点宣称他极其卑鄙且腐败。我认为这其实有点……
unfair because a lot of people have these kinds of funds. And Nixon genuinely was not very well off compared with a lot of politicians. So he kind of needed it to meet his expenses. He wasn't paying his kind of gas bill out of it. He wasn't buying motorhomes. He wasn't, no. He wasn't buying kind of caravan type arrangements and parking in other people's drives or anything. So there were mounting attacks on Nixon.
不公平，因为很多人都有这种类型的基金。与许多政客相比，尼克松确实算不上富有。所以他某种程度上需要它来应付开支。他并不是用它来付煤气费。他没有买房车。他没有，没有。他没有买那种大篷车之类的东西，然后停在别人的车道上或者别的什么地方。因此，针对尼克松的攻击日益加剧。
And Eisenhower, who always really despised Nixon, actually, he's very tempted to drop Nixon from the ticket. So the Eisenhower campaign basically bought time for a TV address and said to Nixon, this is your last chance. You have to explain this on TV. If the public back you, we'll keep you. If they don't back you, basically, you're out. So Nixon's under immense pressure.
而一直真正鄙视尼克松的艾森豪威尔，其实非常想把尼克松从竞选名单中除名。因此，艾森豪威尔的竞选团队基本上购买了一段电视演讲的时间，并对尼克松说：这是你最后的机会。你必须在电视上解释清楚。如果公众支持你，我们就留着你；如果他们不支持你，基本上，你就出局了。所以尼克松承受着巨大的压力。
He goes on TV, gives this speech, and he says, Pat and I are very poor. There's a line he says, which I always like, where he says, Pat doesn't have a mink coat. She has a respectable Republican cloth coat. But I always tell her that she'd look good in anything. Oh, brilliant. At that point, you know, some people are weeping with, you know, lots of people are weeping. Others projectile vomit. Right, exactly.
他上电视发表了这篇演讲，他说：“帕特和我非常穷。”他有一句我一直很喜欢的话，他说：“帕特没有貂皮大衣。她有一件体面的共和党布料大衣。但我总是告诉她，她穿什么都好看。”哦，太精彩了。在那一刻，你知道，有些人感动得泪流满面，（你知道的），很多人在哭泣。其他人则喷射性呕吐。没错，正是这样。
And then he has this fantastic twist where he says, now there's one other thing I have to tell you, because if I don't, they will be saying this about me too. We did get one gift. A man down in Texas had Pat on the radio mentioned the fact that our two youngsters, he's got two girls, Julie and Tricia, would like to have a dog. And believe it or not, the day before we left on this campaign trip, we got a message from Union Station in Baltimore. They had a package for us. We went down to get it. You know what it was? It was a little cocker spaniel dog in a crate that he sent all the way from Texas.
接着他有一个精彩的转折，他说：“现在还有一件事我必须告诉你们，因为如果我不说，他们也会拿这个来做文章。我们确实收到了一个礼物。德克萨斯州的一个人在广播里听到帕特提到我们的两个孩子——他有两个女儿，朱莉和特里西亚——想要一只狗。信不信由你，在我们踏上这次竞选之旅的前一天，我们收到了巴尔的摩联合车站发来的消息。他们为我们准备了一个包裹。我们去把它取了回来。你们知道那是什么吗？是一个装在板条箱里的小可卡犬，是他一路从德克萨斯州寄过来的。”
Black and white spotted. And our little girl, Tricia, the six-year-old, she named it Checkers. And you know what, says Nixon, the kids love the dog. And I just want to say this right now, that regardless of what they say about it, we're going to keep it. Oh, God bless America. Yay for Nixon. Yay for checkers. It's a true story. So it was a Texan salesman called Lou Carroll had genuinely read an article about Pat Nixon, which she said her girls would like a dog. And he had genuinely sent them a telegram and said,
黑白相间的斑点。我们的小女儿特里西亚，六岁的那年，给她起名叫切克斯。你们知道吗，”尼克松说，“孩子们非常喜欢这只狗。我只想现在就表态，不管别人怎么说，我们都要养着它。”哦，上帝保佑美利坚。为尼克松欢呼。为切克斯欢呼。这是一个真实的故事。所以确实有一个名叫路·卡罗尔（Lou Carroll）的德克萨斯州推销员读到了一篇关于帕特·尼克松的文章，文章中说她的女儿们想要一只狗。于是他真的发了一份电报说：
on behalf of the great state of Texas, I'd like you to have this puppy. So the speech is watched by 60 million Americans, which I think is the largest audience at that point in history for a political speech. Nixon says in his memoirs, the TV cameraman was crying at the end of the speech. The switchboard is jammed with supporters. So Nixon stays on the ticket ticket his political career is saved checkers were sent enough dog food to last her a year and they got sent leads they got sent dog toys they get sent collars the veteran columnist walter litman said it was the most demeaning
“代表伟大的德克萨斯州，我希望你们能收下这只小狗。”因此，这场演讲被6000万美国人观看，我认为这是当时历史上政治演讲的最大观众规模。尼克松在回忆录中写道，演讲结束时电视摄像师都在哭泣。总机被支持者的电话打爆了。所以尼克松留在了竞选名单上，他的政治生涯得救了。切克斯收到了足够吃一年的狗粮，他们收到了狗绳、狗玩具、狗项链。资深专栏作家沃尔特·李普曼（Walter Lippmann）说，这是“我国历史上经历过的最卑劣的经历”。
experience my country has ever had to bear in its history god well it's lucky that he died when he did hasn't seen what seen what's come later. Right. The amazing thing is that actually behind the Cheka speech, there's another dog speech, Tom. So this is actually two dogs in one. Oh, brilliant. Because what Nixon had done is the day before he gave that speech, he had remembered a speech
上帝啊，那他死得还挺是时候的，没看到后面发生了什么。没错。神奇的是，其实在切克斯演讲的背后，还有另一场关于狗的演讲，汤姆。所以这实际上是“买一赠一”的两只狗。哦，太棒了！因为尼克松在发表那场演讲的前一天，想起了一场演讲——
that Franklin D. Roosevelt had given in 1944 when Roosevelt was running for his unprecedented fourth term in office. And Roosevelt had been coming under unprecedented fourth term in office. And Roosevelt had been coming under great criticism from the Republicans. And Orson Welles, of all people, had suggested to Roosevelt that he mention his own dog, who was called Fala. And Roosevelt said in this speech, you know, the Republicans are, they're not just content with attacking me and my wife and my sons and my family. They also now include
富兰克林·D·罗斯福在1944年发表的演讲，当时罗斯福正在竞选史无前例的第四任期。罗斯福当时正受到来自共和党人的空前批评。而奥逊·威尔斯（Orson Welles）——偏偏是他——曾建议罗斯福提一下他自己的狗，那只狗叫法拉（Fala）。罗斯福在那场演讲中说，你知道，共和党人，他们不仅满足于攻击我和我的妻子、我的儿子们还有我的家庭。他们现在甚至把——
my little dog, Fala, which was true because the Republicans had been telling this story that Roosevelt had left his dog behind on one of the Aleutian Islands and had sent a destroyer in the middle of the war to go back and pick Fala up, which was completely untrue. But it would have been fair enough even if it had been true. Well, send a destroyer? The American people would rally behind a president's lover, his dog, wouldn't they? Well, Scottish listeners who might have enjoyed the mention of the camper van earlier will enjoy this bit because Roosevelt gave this speech in 1944 to the Teamsters.
我的小狗法拉也牵扯进来了。这确实是真的，因为共和党人当时一直在散布这样一个故事：罗斯福在阿留申群岛之一把狗给落下了一只，并在战争期间派了一艘驱逐舰回去把法拉接回来，这完全是无稽之谈。但即便那是真的，其实也无可厚非。哦？派一艘驱逐舰？美国人民会支持总统的情人，或者他的狗，对吧？好吧，也许会喜欢前面提到露营车的苏格兰听众会喜欢这一段，因为罗斯福是在1944年对卡车司机工会发表这篇演讲的。
And he said, I don't resent my attacks on me by the Republicans. My family don't resent them. But Fowler does resent them because Fowler is Scotch. And being a Scotty, as soon as he learned that Republican fiction writers had concocted this story, his Scotch soul was furious. He has not been the same dog since. I have a right to resent and to object to libelous statements about my dog. So for Nixon to rip, to sort of basically not rip off this story, but to turn it into this populist kind of mawkish fable,
他说：“我不怨恨共和党人对我的攻击。我的家人也不怨恨。但法拉怨恨，因为法拉是苏格兰人（Scotch）。作为一只苏格兰梗（Scotty），一听说共和党的小说家们编造了这个故事，它那颗苏格兰的灵魂就愤怒了。它从此再也不是以前那条狗了。我有权对有关我的狗的诽谤言论表示愤怒和抗议。”所以对于尼克松来说，去剽窃——或者说基本上不是剽窃这个故事，而是把它变成这样一个民粹主义式的、感伤的寓言，
absolutely inflamed Democrats. So everybody would have picked up the reference? Oh, lots of people would. Yeah, lots of people would. Nixon was always incredibly mawkish, but it was a mawkishness that absolutely resonated with a lot of middle America. The funny thing is Nixon actually slightly resented it being remembered for the dog, because it was quite a long speech. So in his memoirs, he always calls it the fund speech. And he barely mentions Chequers at all. Whereas it's remembered as the Chequers speech.
彻底激怒了民主党人。所以每个人都能听懂这个典故？哦，很多人都能。是的，很多人都能。尼克松总是极其多愁善感，但这是一种绝对能与广大美国中产阶级产生共鸣的多愁善感。有趣的是，尼克松其实有点反感人们因为狗而记住他，因为那是一场很长的演讲。所以在他的回忆录里，他总是称之为“基金演讲”（the fund speech）。而且他几乎根本不提切克斯。然而它却作为“切克斯演讲”而被世人铭记。
And there's another bit of history with Nixon and dogs, Tom, because when Nixon did enter the White House, sadly, Chequers was dead. So Chequers is the most famous political dog of all time, but never actually got to go in the White House. So when Nixon goes in in 1969, his staff- He didn't stuff her. No, he didn't. His staff bought him a dog, an Irish Red Setter, whom Nixon called King Timahoe. So there were actually three dogs at that point in the White House, because Julie and Tricia still had dogs. They had dogs called Pasha and Vicky. But King Timahoe didn't initially take to Nixon.
汤姆，尼克松和狗之间还有另一段历史，因为当尼克松入主白宫时，可悲的是，切克斯已经死了。所以切克斯是有史以来最著名的政治狗，但实际上从未能进入白宫。因此，当尼克松于1969年入主白宫时，他的幕僚——他没有把它做成标本。不，他没有。他的幕僚给他买了一只狗，一只爱尔兰红雪达犬，尼克松给它取名叫“蒂马霍国王”（King Timahoe）。所以当时白宫里其实有三只狗，因为朱莉和特里西亚仍然有狗。她们有叫帕莎（Pasha）和维姬（Vicky）的狗。但蒂马霍国王一开始并不买尼克松的账。
So his staff had to leave. They led trails of biscuits all through the White House that led to the Oval Office, to Nixon's desk. And Nixon kept a tin of biscuits. So they bonded eventually, did they? They did bond eventually, I think. There were some stories that his staff, in an attempt to kind of appease the dog,
所以他的幕僚不得不离开。他们一路在白宫里洒下饼干屑，通往椭圆形办公室，通往尼克松的办公桌。而尼克松则保留了一罐饼干。所以他们最终培养出感情了吗？他们最终确实培养出感情了，我想。有一些故事说，他的幕僚为了安抚这只狗，
would throw biscuits around the Oval Office and they broke a clock with a dog biscuit. I don't know. Can you break a clock with a dog biscuit? It would have to be quite a heavy, heavy dog biscuit, wouldn't it? Well, it's the 70s, you know. Yeah, I don't know. Do they have dog biscuits in America?
会在椭圆形办公室里到处扔饼干，结果他们还用狗饼干砸坏了一个时钟。我不知道。你能用狗饼干砸坏一个时钟吗？那得是一块相当沉、相当重的狗饼干吧？好吧，那是70年代嘛，你知道的。对，我不知道。美国真的有狗饼干这种东西吗？
Are they not dog cookies? Yeah. Do they call them dog biscuits? I think they do call them dog biscuits. They're just not consistent, Tom. I don't approve of it, but there you go. Can't be helped. Right, Dominic.
难道不叫狗曲奇吗？对。他们叫它们狗饼干吗？我想他们确实叫狗饼干。它们只是前后不一致，汤姆。我不赞成这样，但事情就是这样。无可奈何。好吧，多米尼克。
So that's our first one. You talked about Morkishness and you talked about Scotland. So listeners will probably be able to guess our second dog, which is probably Scotland's most famous dog, absolute star of Edinburgh tourism. And that, of course, is Greyfriars Bobby. Oh, yes. And this is actually quite a complicated story because... It's a shaggy dog story, Tom.
所以这是我们的第一个。你谈到了多愁善感，你也谈到了苏格兰。所以听众们大概能猜到我们的第二只狗，它可能是苏格兰最著名的狗、爱丁堡旅游业的绝对明星，那当然就是——忠犬波比（Greyfriars Bobby）。哦，是的。这其实是一个相当复杂的故事，因为……
Well, is it? Are sky terriers shaggy? I'm not sure they are. No. Well, they're shaggy in comparison with humans, I suppose. Anyway, so Greyfriars Bobby, he's a sky terrier, very long lived, so 17 years. Supposed to have lived from 1855 to 1872. And as far as we can tell, the likeliest version of the story,
这是一篇又长又啰嗦的“长篇大论”（shaggy dog story）吗，汤姆？嗯？斯凯梗（sky terriers）毛很长吗？我不确定是不是。不。好吧，跟人类比起来毛发算多的吧，我想。不管怎样，所以忠犬波比，它是一只斯凯梗，非常长寿，活了17岁。据说生活于1855年至1872年。据我们所知，最可信的版本——
certainly the earliest, is that he belonged to a night watchman who was called John Gray, who was working for the police, so hence the name Bobby. Ah, nice. Which I'd never got before I read up on this. And John Gray was kind of, he was very very very on his up as working as a night watchman through the night was all he could get um he was basically i mean just above the bread line 1850s is it 1860s yeah 1850s yes so he'd come to edinburgh from the countryside he dies of tb
当然也是最早的版本，是它属于一个名叫约翰·格雷（John Gray）的夜间巡警，他为警察局工作，所以名字叫“波比”（Bobby，译者注：Bobby也是英国对警察的昵称）。啊，真好。我以前读到这个时从来没弄懂过这一点。约翰·格雷的生活可以说是非常、非常拮据，靠当夜间巡警熬过黑夜就是他仅能谋生的手段了。他基本上——我是说，刚好在温饱线挣扎。1850年代？是1860年代吗？对，1850年代。是的，所以他是从乡下来到爱丁堡的，他死于肺结核，
and he's buried in gray fryer's kirkyard which is just off the Royal Mile. And the story goes that every night, the 14 years that Bobby has left, he comes and sits on his master's grave to commemorate him. Oh, that's nice. And this becomes an absolute feature of Edinburgh life. People come and watch him. In due course, in 1867, an act is introduced that requires dogs to be licensed. And there isn't anyone around who can license Greyfriars Bobby. So the Lord Provost of Edinburgh himself pays for Bobby's dog license,
并被安葬在忠犬波比墓地（Greyfriars Kirkyard），就在皇家一英里（Royal Mile）旁。故事流传开来，在波比剩下的14年生命里，它每天晚上都来这里坐在主人的坟墓上纪念他。哦，这太美好了。这成了爱丁堡生活的一个绝对标志。人们来看望它。到了1867年，爱丁堡出台了一项法案，要求对狗进行登记领证。当时周围没有人能替忠犬波比申领狗证。于是爱丁堡市长亲自为波比支付了狗证费用，
buys him a collar. And then when Greyfriars Bobby dies, he is buried in Greyfriars Kirkyard next to his dead master's grave. So it's all very, very touching. He went there every night for 14 years. This is the story. This is the story. How did he know it was his grave?'s grave. So it's all very, very touching. He went there every night for 14 years. This is the story. This is the story. How did he know it was his grave? Dominic, stop asking difficult questions. He did.
给它买了一个项链。然后在忠犬波比死后，它被安葬在忠犬波比墓地它死去的的主人坟墓旁。所以这一切都非常、非常感人。它连续14年每晚都去那里。这就是这个故事。这就是这个故事。它怎么知道那是它的坟墓的？所以这一切都非常、非常感人。它连续14年每晚都去那里。这就是这个故事。这就是这个故事。它怎么知道那是它的坟墓的？多米尼克，别问这么难的问题。它就是知道。
Okay. Not by the smell, surely. It's distinctive odour. Anyway, people are not asking difficult questions like that. They're completely taking it on trust. And by the time that he dies the story has has kind of spread far beyond edinburgh far beyond scotland so even in london a lady called lady burdett coots who is the granddaughter of the founder of the bank coots bank which i think the king is that's where he keeps his money isn't it yeah and uh lady burdett coots sets up a drinking fountain topped by a statue of Bobby opposite the entrance to the graveyard. And we've already mentioned Hobhouse's tribute to Bosun.
好吧。肯定不是靠气味吧？独特的芳香。不管怎样，人们并没有问这样刁钻的问题。他们完全是全盘相信。当它死的时候，这个故事已经传得远远超出了爱丁堡，远超出了苏格兰。甚至在伦敦，有一位名叫伯代特-库茨女士（Lady Burdett-Coutts）的贵妇——她是库茨银行（Coutts Bank，国王存放钱财的那家银行，对吧？是的）创始人的孙女——
Here is another one. The inscription on this memorial is a tribute to the affectionate fidelity of Greyfriars Bobby in 1858. This faithful dog followed the remains of his master to Greyfriars Churchyard and lingered near the spot until his death in 1872. So there is the answer to your sceptical question. He followed the body. If Lady Burdick Cootes believes it, who am I to disagree? Or, Tom, is there a twist? Well, so you have noticed that perhaps there is something not entirely credible about this story. Over the course of the decades that follow, the story becomes basically better and better. Of course.
出资建造了一个饮水喷泉，喷泉顶端就是波比的雕像，位于墓地入口对面。我们刚才已经提到了霍布豪斯对博森的赞美。这里是另一个。这个纪念碑上的铭文是对忠犬波比在1858年表现出的深情忠诚的致敬。这只忠诚的狗跟随主人的遗体来到忠犬波比教堂墓地，并在该处逗留直至1872年去世。所以这就是对你那怀疑论问题的回答。它跟着遗体来的。如果伯代特-库茨女士都相信，我又有什么资格去反驳呢？或者说，汤姆，其中有什么反转吗？好吧，所以你已经注意到，也许这个故事里有些地方并非完全可信。在随后的几十年里，这个故事基本上变得越来越传奇。当然。
So the canonical story, the story that then kind of the various films that have been made um was the result of a story written by an american novelist and journalist called eleanor atkinson you had stowned me tom who in 1912 he wrote this up as a novel right and has a very very heartwarming description of gray fras bobby dawn he was only a little country dog the very youngest and smallest and shaggiest of sky terriers shaggiest i told you it was a shaggy dog story bred on a heathery slope of the pendland hills where the loudest sound was the bark of a collie or the tinkle of a sheep bell did she have the voice of marilyn monroe tom that's that's that's what Tom? That's what early 20th century American novelists
所以经典的叙事——后来据此拍摄的各种电影——是一名叫埃莉诺·阿特金森（Eleanor Atkinson）的美国小说家兼记者创作的一个故事的结果。你把我惊艳到了，汤姆。她在1912年把它写成了一部小说，对吧？其中对忠犬波比的黎明有着非常、非常温馨的描述：“它只是一只乡下小狗，是斯凯梗中最小、最幼小、毛发最蓬松的——”蓬松的我不是告诉过你这是一个毛发蓬松（shaggy dog，双关长篇废话故事）的故事吗？——“出生在彭特兰山（Pentland Hills）的一个满是石南花的斜坡上，那里最大的声音是一只牧羊犬的叫声或羊铃的叮当声。”她说话的声音难道是玛丽莲·梦露吗，汤姆？那就是——那就是——
writing sentimental tales of Scottish dogs. I see now where Richard Nixon got his inspiration from the checker speech. So in this version, John Gray is actually called Old Jock. Of course he is. And the story in this is that he is taking Bobby to a place that did actually exist on
汤姆？那是什么？20世纪初的美国小说家在写关于苏格兰狗狗的感伤故事。我这下明白理查德·尼克松是从哪儿获得切克斯演讲的灵感了。所以在这一版本中，约翰·格雷其实被叫做“老约克”（Old Jock）。当然啦！这里的故事情节是，他正带着波比去一个在爱丁堡坎德尔梅克罗（Candlemaker Row）真实存在的地方——
Candlemaker Row in Edinburgh, Trails Temperance Coffee House at one o'clock every day for lunch. And at one o'clock in Edinburgh, as people will know who visited it, a gun on Edinburgh Castle sounds. And after old Jock or John Gray or whatever we want to call him has died, whenever the gun goes off at one o'clock, Gray Fries Bobby comes to lunch at Trails Temperance Coffee House. And people turn up at Trails Temperance House to watch him. And this is the version that you get in the Disney film.
特雷尔节制咖啡馆（Trails Temperance Coffee House），每天下午一点去吃午饭。正如去过爱丁堡的人所知道的那样，每天下午一点，爱丁堡城堡上会鸣炮。而在老约克或约翰·格雷——或者我们管他叫什么都行——去世之后，每当一点钟大炮响起，忠犬波比就会去特雷尔节制咖啡馆吃午饭。人们会聚在特雷尔节制咖啡馆看它。这就是你在迪士尼电影里看到的版本。
And it's also feeds into the Lassie film that was made. So he's not hanging around at the grave in this story. He is. He's hanging around at the grave and he's going for lunch. So he's got a busy social schedule right exactly yeah and so obviously the question is how true is any of this yeah eyebrows may be raised by the fact that the newspaper that first breaks the story back in 1864 is the the infinites courier which is also the newspaper that first breaks the story of the loch ness monster oh
这也融入了后来拍摄的《灵犬莱西》（Lassie）电影中。所以在这个故事里它不是一直在墓地闲逛？它是在墓地闲逛，然后去吃午饭。所以它有着繁忙的社交日程。完全正确，对。所以显而易见的问题是，这里面有多少是真的？好吧，1864年首次打破沉默报道这个故事的报纸是《爱丁堡信使报》（The Edinburgh Courant），这也是第一家报道尼斯湖水怪故事的报纸，这或许会让人们挑起眉毛。哦！
it's only true it's definitely true but the thing is is that actually bobby was still alive then so unlike the loch ness monster we know that bobby did it did exist maybe the loch ness monster is alive there don't uh yeah but nobody's seen the loch ness monster whereas people were regularly seen this dog going for lunch people are going to see this dog exactly. Exactly. So there is clearly, there is a basis of truth, but there are clearly elements of it that isn't true. Right. So the story of him hearing the gun and going to the Trails Temperance Coffee House isn't true because the firing of the gun was inaugurated after it's supposed to have done.
如果这仅仅是真的——这绝对是真的。但问题在于，其实当时波比还活着。所以不像尼斯湖水怪，我们知道波比确实存在过。也许尼斯湖水怪也活着，别……呃，但是没人见过尼斯湖水怪，而人们却经常看到这只狗去吃午饭。人们确实会看到这只狗去吃午饭。完全正确。所以很显然，这里面有真实的基础，但显然也有并非真实的部分。好吧，关于它听到炮声去特雷尔节制咖啡馆的故事并非真的，因为鸣炮仪式是在它本该这样做之后才开创的。
Oh, wow. So essentially on the principle of Cui Bono, who's benefiting from this, you'd probably say that it's the owner of Trails Temperance Coffeehouse. Oh, yes, you would. So it may be that that entire thing began as a kind of scam originating with John Trail, who owned it. And the other question that skeptics have asked is, was there more than one dog? Because as I said, Greyfriars Bobby seems to have been very long lived for a stray dog in Edinburgh in the mid 19th century. So it's possible that he died and got replaced.
哦，哇！所以基本上根据“谁受益”（Cui Bono）的原则——谁从中获益，你大概会说那是拥有它的约翰·特雷尔（John Trail）。哦，对，你肯定会这么说。所以整件事情可能最初起源于约翰·特雷尔的一场骗局。而怀疑论者提出的另一个问题是：当时是不是不止一只狗？因为正如我所说，对于19世纪中期爱丁堡的一只流浪狗来说，忠犬波比似乎活得太长了。所以它有可能死后被换掉了。
What's this Tom by the reed? Was he even a dog at all? Yeah, he's definitely a dog. No, the huge bombshell, the massive question is, was he actually a Sky Terrier? Because this is the latest development that took place only last year in 2022.
汤姆，这芦苇是怎么回事？它到底是不是一只狗？不，它绝对是一只狗。不，那个巨大的重磅炸弹、最大的问题是：它真的是一只斯凯梗吗？因为这是去年——2022年才刚刚出现的最新进展。
And it's been proposed by Mike, the brilliantly named Mike Macbeth, continuing the Scottish theme. Oh, that's unbelievable. He's actually Canadian. Mike Macbeth? Yes. That's his name? Yeah, that's his name.
这个说法由迈克——顶着个苏格兰风味十足的绝妙名字的迈克·麦克白（Mike Macbeth）提出。哦，这太难以置信了。他其实是个加拿大人。迈克·麦克白？是的。那是他的名字？对，那是他的名字。
Okay. I mean, if he's listening, I hope he's not offended. But he's not Scottish. He's the president of the Canadian Dandy Dinment Terrier Club. The what? And are you a fay Canadian Dandy Dinment Terrier Club. The what? And are you a fay with Dandy Dinments? No, I'm not.
好吧。如果他在听的话，我希望他不要被冒犯。但他不是苏格兰人。他是加拿大丹迪丁蒙特梗俱乐部（Canadian Dandy Dinmont Terrier Club）的主席。什么俱乐部？你对丹迪丁蒙特梗（Dandy Dinmonts）熟悉吗？不，我不熟悉。
Well, we actually had a Dandy Dinment when I was a child. What is it? They're very sweet terriers and they have kind of little tufts. They're grey and they have little tufts. Dandy Dinment is a dog? Yes. And it's named after a cat. Sounds like a nightclub hostess from the 1950s. No.
好吧，我小时候其实养过一只丹迪丁蒙特梗。那是什么？它们是非常可爱的梗犬，有着一小撮一小撮的毛。它们是灰色的，长着一小撮毛。丹迪丁蒙特是一只狗吗？是的。而且它是以一只猫——听起来像是个1950年代的夜总会女领班。不。
No, Dominic. It sounds like what it is. It sounds like a character from one of Walter Scott's novels. it's it sounds like what it is it sounds like a character from one of walter scott's novels okay so that's what it's named after he's a character who appears in in uh guy manning which is one of scott's novels and um they were bred in first bred in 1842 so every dandy denman terrier that there is in the in the world at the moment can trace his ancestry back to um the original Dandy Dinman, who was called Old Ginger.
不，多米尼克。它听起来就像它本来那样。它听起来像是沃尔特·司各特（Walter Scott）小说中的一个角色。它听起来像是它本来那样。它听起来像是沃尔特·司各特小说中的一个角色。好吧，所以这就是它的名字来源。他是一个出现在《盖伊·曼纳林》（Guy Mannering，司各特的小说之一）中的角色。呃，它们最早培育于1842年，所以目前世界上每一只丹迪丁蒙特梗，都可以把它们的血统追溯到……
Is that about the claim that everybody in Britain can trace their ancestry back to Edward III? No. Well, maybe it is. But in the case of Dandy Dinman, I remember that we got a scroll of paper showing the lineage for Jakey, our beloved Dandy Dinman, who I'm very happy to have a reason to mention. And Mike McBeth, who's president of the Canadian Dandy Dinman Terrier Club, thinks that perhaps Greyfriars Bobby was actually Dandy Dinman, who I'm very happy to have a reason to mention. And Mike McBeth, who's president of the Canadian Dandy Dinman Terrier Club, thinks that perhaps Greyfriars Bobby was actually a Dandy Dinman. What a bombshell. Yeah. Tom, golly. So this is what he says. There have been so many competing stories about Greyfriars Bobby that the truth has faded like the mist on an Edinburgh
这就像是说英国每个人都可以把血统追溯到爱德华三世的说法吗？不。好吧，也许是的。但在丹迪丁蒙特梗的例子中，我记得我们曾拿到过一张纸卷轴，上面显示着杰基（Jakey，我们深爱的丹迪丁蒙特梗，我很高兴能有一个提起它的理由）的家谱。而加拿大丹迪丁蒙特梗俱乐部主席迈克·麦克白认为，或许忠犬波比其实是一只丹迪丁蒙特梗。多么震撼的重磅炸弹。是的。汤姆，天哪。所以他是这么说的：关于忠犬波比，有太多相互矛盾的故事，以至于真相就像爱丁堡清晨的雾气一样消散了。
morning. But the more I researched him for our book, The Dandy Dinman Terrier, The True Story of Scotland's Forgotten Breed, the facts led to only one conclusion, that Greyfriars Bobby had to be a Dandy Dinmont. What an extraordinary coincidence that he's the president of the Dandy Dinmont Club. But I don't think you can reasonably claim, Kenny, that Greyfriars Bobby is... I mean, if we're talking about significance, Chequers is much more significant than Greyfriars Bobby. Well, not if you're in the Edinburgh Tourist Board. No, no, admittedly. But if you're working for the Richard Nixon Presidential Library and Museum, there's only one contender. But Dominic, I'm recording this on the banks of the Tweed, or Tweed as we locals call it.
但我在为我们的书《丹迪丁蒙特梗：苏格兰被遗忘品种的真实故事》（The Dandy Dinmont Terrier, The True Story of Scotland's Forgotten Breed）进行研究时，事实指向了唯一的结论——忠犬波比必定是一只丹迪丁蒙特梗。他是丹迪丁蒙特俱乐部的主席，这未免也太巧合了吧。但我觉得你不能合情合理地宣称，肯尼，忠犬波比……我的意思是，如果我们谈论影响力，切克斯可比忠犬波比重要得多。好吧，如果你是在爱丁堡旅游局工作的话。不，不，这倒是真的。但如果你是在理查德·尼克松总统图书馆暨博物馆工作，那就只有一个候选者了。不过，多米尼克，我是在特威德河（Tweed）河畔录制这段节目录音的，或者像我们当地人叫的那样，就叫Tweed。
And so Edinburgh is much closer to me than California. Well, we'll agree to differ on that. I mean, I would say that Greyfriars Bobby is definitely one of the, I mean, absolutely very famous dog, don't you think? It's famous, but it's not significant in the evolution of populism, as Chequers is. Well, and talking about the evolution of populism. Yeah. Who's number three? Our third dog is, so we've had one dog owned by a sinister right-wing leader,
所以爱丁堡离我可比加利福尼亚近多了。好吧，我们在这一点上保留意见。我的意思是，我会说忠犬波比绝对是——我的意思是，绝对是一只非常著名的狗，你不觉得吗？它很有名，但它在民粹主义演变中的重要性不及切克斯。好吧，说到民粹主义的演变。是的。第三只是谁？我们的第三只狗是——我们已经有一只属于某个阴暗的右翼领导人的狗了，
and now we have another, another dog owned by a sinister right-wing leader. Does Liz Truss have a dog? This is Blondie, who was owned by famous animal lover, Adolf Hitler. Tom, I can't believe you've gone there. Blondie is your number three. Well, Nixon, of course. Nixon. Hitler.
现在我们又有一只属于某个阴暗的右翼领导人的狗。莉兹·特拉斯（Liz Truss）有狗吗？这是布隆迪（Blondie），属于著名的动物爱好者阿道夫·希特勒。汤姆，我简直不敢相信你把话题引到这儿来了。布隆迪竟然是你的第三名。好吧，尼克松当然是。尼克松。希特勒。
Hitler was a big dog lover, wasn't he? Well, our Democrats cheer. Because Hitler had been messing around with dogs in the trenches in World War I. Because in my adventure in time, Second World War, it's a great opportunity for me to advertise my excellent children's book in which um the fuhrer appears as a as a major character the book begins with hitler and um he's just a young man he's in the trenches and he has a dog and when i wrote the first draft of that chapter and i showed it to my son he said you've got to cut the dog because all children will assume that a young man yes it's a hero it He said, you've got to cut the dog because all children will assume that a young man with a dog…
希特勒是个狂热的爱狗人士，对吧？好吧，我们的民主党人要欢呼了。因为希特勒曾在第一次世界大战的战壕里和狗混在一起。在我的“时间历险记：第二次世界大战”中，这是一个绝佳的机会，让我可以宣传我那本极好的儿童书，书中——元首作为一个主要角色出场。这本书以希特勒开场，呃，他当时只是个年轻人，在战壕里，他有一只狗。当我写完那一章的第一稿并把它拿给我儿子看时，他说：“你必须把狗删掉，因为所有的儿童都会想当然地认为，一个带着狗的年轻人——”
Yes, it's the hero. It's the hero. And Hitler had a dog which was a Jack Russell, a white Jack Russell. Supposedly, initially the property of a British soldier, a Tommy, who had found its way into the trenches. And Hitler had adopted the dog and he called him… So he'd stolen it. He'd stolen an Englishman's pet.
是的，那就是英雄。那就是英雄。希特勒曾有一只狗，是一只杰克罗素梗（Jack Russell），一只白色的杰克罗素梗。据说最初是一个英国士兵——一个“汤米”（Tommy）——的财产，不知怎么跑进了战壕里。希特勒收养了这只狗，他给它起名叫……所以他是偷来的。他偷了一个英国人的宠物。
Well, Hitler called him Fuschel, which means little fox. And he wrote, I think later, he says, how many times I used to study my dog Fuschel. I used to watch him as if he was a man. It was crazy how fond I was of that beast. And the story is that in 1917, Hitler moves down the line. His regiment moved to Alsaceace i think and um a railroad official offers nixon some money for the dog and nixon says no you can you could offer me 200 000 marks i wouldn't part with him but then when they come to leave nick uh have i called him nixon again anyway yes oh no terrible this is terrible. Hitler goes off and he leaves.
好吧，希特勒叫它“福舍尔”（Fuschel），意思是“小狐狸”。他后来写道，我想：“我曾多少次端详我的狗福舍尔。我观察它就像观察一个人一样。我对那头野兽的喜爱简直疯狂。”故事是这样的：在1917年，希特勒调防。他的团调到了阿尔萨斯（Alsace）我想，呃，一个铁路官员出钱向尼克松买这只狗，而尼克松说不，你出20万马克我也不会跟他分开。但后来当他们要离开时，尼克——我怎么又叫他尼克松了？不管怎样，是的，哦，不，太糟糕了，这太糟糕了。希特勒离开时，他把狗落下了。
He can't find the dog. And he assumes the railroad official may have stolen him. He never sees the dog again. Oh. And, Tom, this is a great what if of history, isn't it? Yes. If Hitler had found that dog. Maybe he'd have been a nicer person.
他找不到那只狗了。他猜测那个铁路官员可能把它偷走了。他再也没见过那只狗。哦。汤姆，这是历史上的一个巨大“如果”，对吧？是的。如果希特勒找到了那只狗……也许他会变成一个更好的人。
Maybe. Maybe. Maybe his demons wouldn't have been quite so murderous. Exactly. But he had lots of dogs, actually. He was very into German shepherds, which were hugely popular with the kind of nationalist right. Absolutely. Because they were Aryan dogs, if that's such a thing. Well, so their full name is Canis lupus familiaris.
也许吧。也许他的心魔就不会那么嗜杀成性了。没错。但他其实有很多狗，他对德国牧羊犬非常着迷，这种狗在民族主义右翼中极受欢迎。绝对的。因为它们是雅利安狗，如果真有这种说法的话。好吧，所以它们的学名是 Canis lupus familiaris。
And lupus, of course, is wolf in Latin. And the Nazis were very, very into dogs who were close to wolves because wolves were seen as belonging to the primordial German forest and embodying Aryan kind of values of ferocity and strength and things like that. And the most famous of all the German shepherds owned by Hitler was one that Martin Bormann, who also loved German shepherds, gave him in 1941. And this is Blondie. Yeah. He loved Blondie, didn't he?
而 lupus，当然就是拉丁语中的“狼”。纳粹对那些接近狼的狗非常、非常着迷，因为狼被视为属于原始的日耳曼森林，体现了雅利安人那种凶猛、力量之类的价值观。而希特勒拥有的所有德国牧羊犬中最著名的一只，是马丁·鲍曼（Martin Bormann）——他也酷爱德国牧羊犬——在1941年送给他的。这就是布隆迪（Blondie）。对。他很爱布隆迪，不是吗？
He did. And Blondie featured a lot in Nazi propaganda. So Hitler was always kind of shown with Blondie, kept her by his side in his various retreats and things like that. And in 1945, when he goes to the bunker, he takes Blondie with him into the bunker and lets her sleep on the bed, which Ava Brown was not keen on at all. She had dogs of her own, though. Scottish Terriers again. Okay.
他确实很爱。布隆迪在纳粹宣传中频频亮相。所以希特勒总是被拍到和布隆迪在一起，把它留在身边的各个隐蔽所和类似的地方。到了1945年，当他进入地堡时，他把布隆迪带进了地堡，并让它睡在床上，爱娃·布劳恩对此非常反感。不过她自己也有狗。又是苏格兰梗。好的。
One of whom, weirdly, was called Starzy. Starzy. Strange. Starzy is the East German. Yeah, secret police. There's a Graham hancock series in this tom yeah so why do why did they name their security service after a dog owned by hitler's wife because blonde is not a good name for a security service i suppose that's true yes i
其中一只，奇怪的是，叫斯塔西（Starzy）。斯塔西。奇怪。斯塔西是东德的……是的，秘密警察。这简直可以拍成一部格雷姆·汉考克（Graham Hancock）系列片了，汤姆。是的。那他们为什么要把他们的安全部门以希特勒妻子的狗命名呢？因为“布隆迪”作为安全部门的名字可不太好听，我想也是。是的。
suppose that's true anyway so um march 1945 even as the uh the soviets are closing in blondie has a whole litter of puppies, which is lovely of Hitler. But then 29th of April, he knows it's all over. He's got the cyanide. He's not certain it's going to work. Yeah. And so he tries it out on Blondie.
我想也是。不管怎样，1945年3月，甚至在苏联军队步步逼近的时候，布隆迪生了一窝小狗，希特勒对此很高兴。但到了4月29日，他知道一切都结束了。他拿到了氰化物。他不确定这药管不管用。对。所以他在布隆迪身上做了实验。
It does work. He's absolutely distraught when Blondie dies. Which he thinks was going to happen. I mean, that's madness. Give a dog cyanide. Well, I suppose part of him would have wanted it to work because then he'd know that he'd be able to commit suicide and he wouldn't be captured.
确实管用。当布隆迪死时，他痛不欲生。他本来以为会这样的。我的天，这太疯狂了。给一只狗喂氰化物。好吧，我想他内心的一部分可能希望它管用，因为这样他就知道自己能够自杀而不会被俘虏了。
But I guess the other half of him, he'd be very sad at losing Blondie, who he obviously adored. And then the 30th of April, Hitler commits suicide, Ava as well. And after they're both dead, their guards get the puppies that blondies just delivered and shoot them all oh my god and they get burned with the bodies of they burn the dogs as well hitler and
但我猜他的另一半心理是，失去他明显宠爱的布隆迪会让他非常难过。然后在4月30日，希特勒自杀身亡，爱娃也一样。在他们双双身亡后，他们的卫兵拿到了布隆迪刚生下的小狗并把它们全部枪杀——哦，天哪。而且它们和希特勒、爱娃的尸体一起被焚烧了——他们把狗也烧了。
ava yeah because the bodies fell into the possession of the red army and it's crazy well i don't know what happened to starzy it's an odd one isn't it choosing hitler's dog because it humanizes hitler i mean actually what my son said about having Hitler with a dog in the children's history book was right in a way. It's interesting how possession of an animal, having a relationship with an animal does humanize people, even terrible villains. I think it's interesting that people are fascinated by Hitler and his dogs because we think of Hitler as inhuman, as cold, as unfeeling. And to see him... But isn't it a part of it? You say inhuman as cold as unfeeling and just show i'd see him you know but isn't isn't it a part of it you say inhuman i mean famously he's vegetarian because he doesn't want to to eat the meat of dead animals like you tom like me um well i'm not really i eat fish as well don't care about fish
希特勒和爱娃。因为尸体落入了红军手中，这太疯狂了。好吧，我不知道斯塔西后来怎么样了。这真是个奇怪的现象，不是吗？选择希特勒的狗，因为这把希特勒人性化了。我的意思是，其实我儿子在儿童历史书里说把希特勒和狗放在一起很不妥，从某种程度上说也是对的。有趣的是，拥有动物、与动物建立关系，确实能让人性化，哪怕是可怕的恶魔。我觉得有趣的是，人们对希特勒和他的狗着迷，是因为我们认为希特勒是不人道的、冷酷的、麻木不仁的。看到他……但难道这不正是其中一部分吗？你说不人道、冷酷、麻木不仁，然后展现我看到他，你知道的——但难道，难道这不正是其中一部分吗？你说不人道，我的意思是，众所周知他是素食主义者，因为他不想吃死动物的肉，就像你一样，汤姆。像我一样。嗯，其实我不是，我也吃鱼。我才不在乎鱼呢。
um i mean the thing the thing is isn't it that it it's Hitler's devotion to animals rather than to humans that is so unsettling about him? Yeah. In a way, it humanizes him. But in another way, it kind of just intensifies the spendthrift way in which he destroys millions and millions of people's lives without care. That's actually a good point. It probably is more unsettling than if he was, because if he was complete, had no emotions at all. He was just evil. Yes.
嗯，我的意思是，事情的关键在于，希特勒对动物的喜爱而非对人类的喜爱，才是最让人感到不安的，对吧？是的。某种程度上，这让他显得更有人性。但在另一方面，这也更加凸显了他那种挥霍无度、毫不吝惜地毁灭千百万人生命的做法。这确实是个很好的观点。这可能比他完全没有感情、纯粹是个恶魔还要更令人不安。是的。
Yeah. It's more unsettling. Agreed. Tom, we've spent so long talking about these dogs that we're going to run out of time. We've got four more to come. Yeah. God, I can't wait.
没错。更让人不安。同意。汤姆，我们花在这些狗身上的时间太长了，我们的时间快不够了。我们还有四只狗要讲。是的。天哪，我等不及了。
So, listen, join us after the break for more of history's greatest dogs. Woof, woof. Oh, Tom. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
所以，听着，中场休息后加入我们，了解更多历史上的伟大名犬。汪，汪。哦，汤姆。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《其余皆娱乐》。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论，
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking dogs with top dog lover
以及各种八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们将带你一探娱乐幕后，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番外以及提前获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《其余皆历史》。今天我们和顶级爱狗人士
Tom Holland. Tom, I believe you've got an apology to make to the listeners. Is that right? I do have an apology to make. So you may have been hearing a strange creaking sound. And that strange creaking sound comes from the chair of our friends who are still up in Scotland at the moment. And we have no Wi-Fi on our side of the Tweed. So I cross over and I'm using theirs. It's definitely the chair, Tom. And it is definitely the chair. And not the ghost of your dandy Dinmont dog. Jakey.
汤姆·霍兰德一起聊狗。汤姆，我想你得向听众道个歉，对吗？我确实得道个歉。大家可能一直听到一种奇怪的咯吱声。这奇怪的咯吱声来自于我们那些目前还在苏格兰的朋友们的椅子。而且特威德河我们这一侧没有 Wi-Fi。所以我借用了他们的。这绝对是椅子的声音，汤姆。这绝对是椅子的声音。而不是你那只丹迪丁蒙梗。杰基的鬼魂。
Oh, I wish it was. Bless him. You've got four dogs and you've got half an hour. Four dogs. Yes. So the fourth one. So there are a lot of kind of mystic, legendary dogs. I could have chosen Argus, who was the dog of Odysseus, very famous. You remember the story that Odysseus has been away, the Trojan War for 10 years, and then he's been wandering around the Mediterranean for another 10 years. And he arrives back in Ithaca disguised as a beggar, and no one recognizes him except for Argus, his old dog who's been thrown out by the evil suitors
哦，我希望是。保佑他。你有四只狗，而你只有半小时。四只狗。是的。所以第四只。这里有很多某种神秘的、传说中的狗。我本可以选择阿耳戈斯，他是奥德修斯的狗，非常有名。你还记得这个故事：奥德修斯离家参加特洛伊战争10年，然后在另一个10年里在地中海漂泊。他乔装成乞丐回到伊萨卡，没有人认出他，除了阿耳戈斯，他的老狗，这只狗被宫殿里邪恶的求婚者们
from the palace and is lying on a dung heap. And as Odysseus walks by cunningly disguised as a beggar, he looks up, recognizes him, whimpers, licks his hand and dies. So very moving. But I'm not including him because Argus didn't actually exist okay instead on the whole kind of mythic legendary dog front i've gone for one who might have existed might so so it's a great story and this dog is called gellert and gellert is supposed to have been owned by luellen the great who was the great welsh prince in the first half of the 13th century king of gwynedd yeah the last great flourishing of independent wales before the conquest bade in the first half of the 13th century. King of Gwynedd. Yeah. The last great flourishing of independent Wales before the conquest paired with the first. And the story goes that Llywelyn the Great, he has a little baby boy.
赶了出来，正躺在粪堆上。当奥德修斯巧妙地伪装成乞丐走过时，它抬起头，认出了他，呜咽着，舔了舔他的手，然后死去了。非常感人。但我没选它，因为阿耳戈斯其实并不存在。好吧，所以在所有这些神话传奇狗的方面，我选了一只可能存在过的狗，有可能。所以，这是一个很棒的故事，这只狗叫格莱特。据说格莱特是卢埃林大王（Llywelyn the Great）的狗，卢埃林大王是13世纪前半叶伟大的威尔士亲王，圭内德国王。对，这是在征服之前，独立威尔士最后的盛世。在13世纪前半叶。圭内德国王。对。在征服与第一结合之前，独立威尔士最后的盛世。故事是这样的：卢埃林大王有一个刚出生的男婴。
The baby boy is left in a crib, guarded by Gellert, who is his dog. And Llywelyn the Great goes out hunting, leaves Gellert behind to stand guard over his son. Llywelyn has a great day out shooting deer or whatever it is he's doing. Comes back and he finds Gellert lying next to an empty crib and Gellert has blood all over his jaws. And so Llewellyn leaps to the logical conclusion that Gellert has eaten the baby. And so he draws his sword and slices off Gellert's head, cleans his sword, wanders into the next room. And there he hears the cries of his baby son. And he looks round and there is a dead wolf, which had attacked the child, but been killed by Gellert. So Gellert had
男婴被放在婴儿床里，由他的狗格莱特守卫。卢埃林大王出去打猎，把格莱特留下看守他的儿子。卢埃林度过了美好的一天，射鹿或是干别的什么。回来后，他发现格莱特躺在一个空婴儿床旁边，格莱特的嘴边沾满了血。于是，卢埃林顺理成章地得出结论：格莱特把婴儿给吃了。于是他拔出宝剑，砍下了格莱特的头，擦拭了宝剑，走进隔壁房间。在那里，他听到了自己婴儿儿子的哭声。他环顾四周，发现了一只死狼，这只狼袭击了孩子，但被格莱特杀死了。所以格莱特其实是
actually died defending the baby boy. And that's why he had blood all over his jaws and llewellyn of course is absolutely crippled with remorse and sense of bereavement yeah and he buries the dog with tremendous ceremony and the story goes that from that point on he never smiled again crikey that is a sad story isn't it it is a sad story, isn't it? It is a sad story. The thing that slightly worries me about that story is I think I've heard that story before in other contexts. Like what? I don't know, but it just seems to me like a very... You can't bring your scepticism to such a moving tale and not be able to justify it.
为了保卫小男孩而牺牲的。这就是为什么它的嘴边沾满了血。而卢埃林，当然陷入了极度的懊悔和丧子之痛中。是的，他以极高的礼遇安葬了这只狗。传说从那以后，他再也没有笑过。天哪，真是个悲伤的故事，不是吗？这确实是个悲伤的故事，不是吗？这确实是个悲伤的故事。让我对这个故事略感担心的是，我好像在别的语境下听过这个故事。比如什么？我不知道，但这给我的感觉非常……你不能把你的怀疑态度带入这样一个感人的故事中，却又无法为此辩解。
That feels to me like an Icelandic saga stroke Greek myth dog story. No. Do you not think? No, it definitely happened to ellen and the proof of that is that it was written up in a splendid poem in the 18th century by a guy called william roberts spencer he kind of hung out with the wigs with charles james fox and all the lads oh yeah holland house prince regent sheridan holland house all that kind of thing and he wrote um a great poem about this shall i read a section of it i think you should read the whole poem frankly i can't because it's enormously long it's one of
这给我的感觉就像是一个冰岛萨迦或希腊神话中的狗狗故事。不。你不觉得吗？不，这绝对发生在卢埃林身上，证据是它在18世纪被一个叫威廉·罗伯茨·斯宾塞（William Robert Spencer）的家伙写成了一首精彩的诗。他曾与查尔斯·詹姆斯·福克斯（Charles James Fox）和辉格党的一帮年轻人厮混。哦，是的。荷兰宫，摄政王，谢里丹，荷兰宫，诸如此类。他写了一首关于这件事的伟大诗篇。我要读一段吗？我觉得你应该朗读整首诗，说实话。我不能，因为它太长了。它是那种
those 18th century very long poems right okay so this is after llewellyn has come in and he's full of remorse and yeah he raises a tomb for gellert and it stands in the forest and here never could the spearman past or forester unmoved here oft the tear besprinkled grass Llewellyn's sorrow proved and here he hung his horn and spear and there as evening fell in fancy's ear he oft would hear poor Gellert's dying yell and till great Snowdon's rocks grow old and cease the storm to brave the consecrated spot shall hold the name of gellert's grave tom i think there was a bit of a tremble in your voice during some of that poem because it's very moving isn't it it's so moving poor gellert and our welsh listeners sometimes complain that we don't do enough welsh history i think that they will feel that we've more than adequately... That beautiful reading from an English poem.
18世纪非常长的诗。好吧，好吧。所以这是在卢埃林进来之后，他充满了懊悔，是的，他为格莱特建造了一座陵墓，它矗立在森林里。在这里，长矛手和护林员从未能平静地走过，在这里，泪水洒满的草地见证了卢埃林的悲伤。在这里，他挂上了号角和长矛，而在夜幕降临时，在幻想的耳边，他常常会听到可怜的格莱特垂死的哀号。直到斯诺don的巨石变老，不再经受风暴的考验，这块神圣的土地将永远保留格莱特之墓的名字。汤姆，我刚才听你朗读这首诗的时候，声音好像有点颤抖，因为它真的很感人，不是吗？太感人了。可怜的格莱特。我们的威尔士听众有时抱怨我们做的威尔士历史不够多。我想他们会觉得我们已经相当充分地……来自一首英文诗的优美朗读。
Well, we're English as well. We're paying homage to the glories of the splendid Welsh dog. Okay, very good. I enjoyed that, Gellert. I don't believe Gellert existed, but I enjoyed the poem nonetheless. So give us a dog that did exist. Well, the next dog is a Pekingese. Okay.
好吧，我们也是英国人。我们在向这只出色的威尔士狗狗的辉煌致敬。好吧，非常好。我很喜欢这个故事，格莱特。我不相信格莱特真的存在，但我还是很喜欢这首诗。那么，给我们讲一只确实存在的狗吧。好的，下一只狗是一只北京犬。好吧。
In fact, it's the very first Pekingese that was brought to Britain. It was brought to Britain in 1861. And it's a story that doesn't reflect tremendously well on Britain. Oh, Tom, do you think we do this podcast to hear this sort of nonsense? And when I tell you that the Pekingese was given to Queen Victoria and she named it Luti. You may be able to guess how and why this dog was obtained when I remind you that in 1860, so the year before it arrives back in Britain, an Anglo-French force had marched on Beijing, on Peking, as they called it then, and sacked the old Summer Palace. Oh yeah, the burning of the Summer Palace. Very great scene in Flashman. Right. So you know all about it from Flashman. So just tell us about the sack of the Summer Palace. Oh yeah, the burning of the Summer Palace. Very great scene in Flashman. Right, so you know all about it from Flashman.
事实上，它是被带到英国的第一只北京犬。它是在1861年被带到英国的。这个故事并不能为英国增光多少。哦，汤姆，你觉得我们做这个播客就是为了听这种无稽之谈吗？当我告诉你这只北京犬被送给维多利亚女王，她给它起名叫鲁蒂（Luti）时。当你回想起在1860年——也就是它被带回英国的前一年，一支英法联军向北京进军，也就是他们当时说的Peking，洗劫了圆明园时，你大概能猜出这只狗是如何以及为什么被得到的了。哦，对，火烧圆明园。弗莱士曼（Flashman）里非常精彩的一个场景。没错。所以你对弗莱士曼的书了如指掌。那么，给我们讲讲洗劫圆明园的事吧。哦，对，火烧圆明园。弗莱士曼里非常精彩的一个场景。没错，所以你对弗莱士曼的书了如指掌。
So just tell us about the sack of the Summer Palace. So it's the Second Opium War. Yeah, so okay. So the Summer Palace was the, it's such a terrible cliche, but I'm going to say it anyway. It was the jewel in the crown of the Chinese Empress' possessions.
那就给我们讲讲洗劫圆明园的事吧。所以这是第二次鸦片战争。是的，好吧。所以圆明园是——这是一个老掉牙的陈词滥调，但我还是要说。它是中国皇后所有财产中的掌上明珠。
It's got these magnificent gardens and pavilions. It's absolutely stuffed with treasures, with artworks, with vases, with all this sort of stuff. Because it's basically, it's absolutely stuffed with treasures with artworks with vases with all this sort of stuff because it's basically it's the british museum crossed with what regent's park yeah i guess so and crossed with buckingham palace i suppose if you can imagine it all in one complex yeah it's the second opium war the chinese had seized the allied negotiators the delegates and they tortured them and stuff it's absolutely superbly done the
那里有壮丽的花园和亭台楼阁。里面塞满了奇珍异宝、艺术品、花瓶以及各种各样诸如此类的东西。因为基本上，它里面塞满了奇珍异宝、艺术品、花瓶以及各种各样诸如此类的东西，因为基本上，它就是大英博物馆加上摄政公园——是的，我猜是这样——再加上白金汉宫，如果你能把所有这些想象成一个综合体的话。是的，那是第二次鸦片战争。中国人扣押了盟军的谈判代表、特使，还虐待他们等等。乔治·麦克唐纳·弗莱士曼（George MacDonald Fraser）的小说中，那种
pathos of it in george mcdonald fraser's novel because lord elgin who's the son of yes the lord elgin as in the path of frases he basically orders the destruction of the summer palace in retribution for what's happened sort of allied the european negotiators and the british and french just basically storm in they burn they smash they steal they kind of level the whole thing they they actually general gordon probably the preeminent friend of the rest is history he was present at the sack of the he was appalled by it wasn't he was he said it made one's heart sore as in sore as in painful yeah to see the burning of all the artworks and the gold ornaments being destroyed and the things being torn down and vases smashed, but also people making off for tons and Britain to bandits. So it was seen at the time as a pretty shocking thing to have done. And so that's why the idea of looting is kind of very much in the air and why
悲凉感被刻画得极其出色。因为埃尔金勋爵（Lord Elgin）——是的，就是那个埃尔金勋爵，正如……他基本上下令摧毁圆明园，作为对欧洲谈判代表遭遇的报复。英法联军直接冲进去，烧毁、砸烂、偷窃、将整个地方夷为平地。事实上，戈登将军——也许是《其余皆历史》最杰出的朋友——他当时就在洗劫现场。他对这一幕感到震惊，不是吗？他说这让人心痛——痛是指痛苦——看到所有的艺术品和黄金饰品被摧毁，东西被撕碎，花瓶被打碎，人们还趁火打劫运走大量的财宝。所以这在当时被认为是一件相当令人震惊的事情。这就是为什么“掠夺”（looting）这个概念当时在空气中弥漫，为什么
Queen Victoria, when she's presented with this little dog, kind of makes a joke of it. So it was found by a guy called John Hart Dunn, who was a military man, served in the Crimean War, very patriotic. When he was out in China, serving with the French, he would make a point whenever they captured somewhere of running up the Union Jack before the tricolor could be raised over concrete forts. And so he's there in the Summer Palace. And he wrote this autobiography later, and he described looting Luti. And he described her as a pretty little dog, smaller than any King Charles, a real Chinese sleeve dog. It had silver bells around its neck and people say it is the most perfect little beauty they ever saw. And so he takes this little dog. I mean, it has to be said in exactly the same way
维多利亚女王在获赠这只小狗时，会拿它开玩笑。这只狗是一个叫约翰·哈特·邓恩（John Hart Dunn）的人发现的，他是一名军人，曾在克里米亚战争中服役，非常爱国。当他在中国跟随法军服役时，每当他们攻克什么地方，他都会特地在混凝土堡垒上升起英国国旗，赶在三色旗升起之前。所以他在圆明园。他后来写了这本自传，并在书中描述了掠夺鲁蒂的过程。他把她描述为一只漂亮的小狗，比任何查理王小猎犬都要小，是一只真正的中国袖珍犬。它的脖子上挂着银铃，人们说这是他们见过的最完美的小美人。于是他带走了这只小狗。我的意思是，必须指出的是，这和
that the Chinese, when they go on imperial adventures, bring animals back. Like the Romans, the Chinese had been kind of bringing animals as evidence of their conquests as evidence of their triumphs back to their capital and now basically john hart dunn is doing the same because he takes this piccanese back to england on the voyage home he has a kind of cap and he has a little piccanese sleep in it and he presents it to queen victoria and victoria i'm afraid to say slightly disgr herself, not only by giving her the name that she gives the dog. This is honest. I guess it is honest, but she doesn't look after Lutie at all well.
中国人在进行皇家探险时带回动物的做法完全一样。就像罗马人一样，中国人一直把动物作为他们征服的证据、胜利的证据带回他们的首都。现在基本上约翰·哈特·邓恩也在做同样的事情，因为他把这只北京犬带回了英国。在回程的航海中，他有一个帽子，让这只小北京犬睡在里面，并把它呈献给维多利亚女王。我遗憾地说，维多利亚女王稍微有些失态，不仅给她起了那个名字。这确实很诚实。我猜这确实很诚实，但她把鲁蒂照顾得一点也不好。
So Lutie is a palace dog and therefore is used to being fed delicate, you know, perfectly cooked portions of chicken. Delicious, soft, light rice. But Queen Victoria feeds her on offal, which is very declassé. I think it's trying to build the dog up. And Lutie is painted by a German student of Edwin Landseer, as in Monarch of the Glen. Yeah. Very popular painter with Queen Victoria. But then once she's been painted, she gets taken away to the kennels in Windsor and Queen Victoria basically ignores her. And she died in 1872
所以鲁蒂是一只宫廷犬，因此习惯了被喂食精致的、你知道的、完美烹饪的鸡肉部分。美味、松软、清淡的米饭。但维多利亚女王却用内脏喂它，这非常不入流。我想这可能是为了给狗狗增肥。鲁蒂被埃德温·兰瑟（Edwin Landseer，《峡谷君主》的作者）的一名德国学生画了下来。是的。维多利亚女王非常喜欢的画家。但一旦它被画下来，就被带到了温莎的犬舍里，维多利亚女王基本上就忽视了它。它于1872年去世，
and is buried in an unmarked grave. So I guess if you wanted a metaphor, if you were straining, if you were being harsh on the British Empire, Lutie would be quite a good metaphor. Okay. Tom, can you remedy this with a more patriotic dog? Yes, I absolutely can. Because obviously we are a very patriotic dog. Yes. Good. I absolutely can. Splendid. Because obviously we are a very patriotic podcast, and so I didn't want to leave it on that note. No. So now we come to very much a friend of the show, Admiral Collingwood, who people who
被埋在一个无名墓穴里。所以我想，如果你想要一个隐喻，如果你勉强去做，如果你对大英帝国严厉一点的话，鲁蒂会是一个相当不错的隐喻。好吧。汤姆，你能用一只更爱国的狗来弥补这一点吗？是的，我绝对可以。因为显然我们是一只非常爱国的狗。是的。很好。我绝对可以。太棒了。因为显然我们是一个非常爱国的播客，所以我不想以那种调子结束。不。所以现在我们要讲一个节目的老朋友，科林伍德海军上将（Admiral Collingwood）。听过我们关于特拉法加海战那一集的
listen to our episode on the Battle of Trafalgar will remember. Cuthbert Collingwood, hero of the Battles of St. Vincent, Trafalgar, kind of Nelson's right-hand man, friend, successor. And again, I'm up here in, well, I've crossed the Tweed. So I was in Scotland and now I'm in England, in the northeast of England, which is very much where Cuthbert Collingwood came from. So he was born and raised in Newcastle. Named after St. Cuthbert, Tom.
听众会记得他。库思伯特·科林伍德（Cuthbert Collingwood），圣文森特战役、特拉法加海战的英雄，可以说是纳尔逊的右手、朋友、继承人。再说一次，我现在在——好吧，我穿过了特威德河。所以我刚才在苏格兰，现在我在英格兰，在英格兰东北部，这正是库思伯特·科林伍德的故乡。所以他在纽卡斯尔出生并长大。以圣库思伯特命名，汤姆。
It all stitches together. Yeah. So anyway, so he's very much a naval man. In 1790, he is given Bounce, this little puppy. What's Bounce? Not entirely sure. Oh, okay. So basically a generic dog.
一切都串联起来了。是的。总之，他是一个地道的海军军人。1790年，他得到了小狗“Bounce”（弹跳）。Bounce是什么？不太确定。哦，好吧。基本上就是一只普通的狗。
A generic dog. Okay. People can use their imaginations. He could be massive. He could be tiny. I don't think he's massive. I don't think he's tiny. I don't think he's massive.
一只普通的狗。好吧。人们可以发挥想象力。它可能很大。也可能很小。我觉得它不会很大。我觉得它不会很小。我觉得它不会很大。
I think he's kind of- A medium dog. He's a medium dog. He's an average dog. Yeah, okay. And 1790, when Collingwood gets Bounce, he is due to go off on a trip to the Caribbean. And so he takes Bounce with him and he writes back to his wife and says that Bounce is a very good dog, delights in the ship, swims after him whenever he goes in the boat.
我觉得它有点像——一只中型犬。它是一只中型犬。它是一只普通的狗。是的，好吧。1790年，科林伍德得到Bounce时，他正要去加勒比海旅行。于是他带着Bounce一起去，并写信给妻子说Bounce是一只很好的狗，在船上玩得很开心，每当他下小艇时，它都会跟着游过去。
So it's good to know that Bounce is getting his sea legs. And from that point on, whenever Collingwood goes to sea he takes bounce with him bounce isn't entirely suited i mean he's he's fine he's got sea legs but he's not entirely suited to um naval engagements because he doesn't like loud noises no dog does dogs hate fireworks i don't know what they would make of a cannon exactly so having loads of cannon firing. So whenever there's a battle being fought, Bounce kind of went below decks and kind of hid beneath a blanket. And after the battle, Collingwood would go and find Bounce. Bounce would be shaking and shivering under his blanket, deep in the bowels of the ship. And Collingwood would pick Bounce up, stroke him and sing him a beautiful lullaby, which was adapted from famous lines in much do about nothing shakespeare's play and it went sigh no more bouncy sigh no more dogs were deceivers never though now you put one foot
所以很高兴得知Bounce正在适应海上生活。从那时起，每当科林伍德出海，他都会带着Bounce。Bounce并不完全适合——我的意思是，它很好，它适应了海上生活，但它并不完全适合……海军交战，因为它不喜欢巨响。没有狗喜欢。狗讨厌烟花。我不知道它们对大炮会有什么反应。所以会有大量的大炮轰鸣。因此，每当有战斗打响时，Bounce就会跑到甲板下，躲在毯子底下。战斗结束后，科林伍德会去找Bounce。Bounce会在他的毯子底下瑟瑟发抖，躲在船舱的最深处。然后科林伍德会把Bounce抱起来，抚摸它，为它唱一首美丽的摇篮曲，这首曲子改编自莎士比亚戏剧《无事生非》中的著名台词：
on shore trust your master ever then sigh not so but let us go where dinner's daily ready converting all the sounds of woe to high fiddly diddy to high fiddly diddy so we've had some great poetry on this episode. We have. That doesn't strike the martial note for me, Tom, I have to say. But that's what's so charming about Collingwood. Yeah, I guess so. He's a hard man in battle, wins a lot of battles, but loves his dog.
别再叹气了，Bounce，别再叹气了。男人向来不可信，虽然现在你一只脚踏上了岸，但要永远信任你的主人。所以别再叹气了，让我们去那晚餐天天准备好的地方，把所有的悲伤之声，化作高亢的 fiddle-di-di，化作高亢的 fiddle-di-di。所以我们在这一集里听到了很多伟大的诗歌。是的。这并没有为我敲响威武的战鼓，汤姆，我必须这么说。但这就是科林伍德迷人的地方。是的，我猜是这样。他在战斗中是个硬汉，赢了很多战役，但也深爱他的狗。
Yeah. And when he's back at home, he's not at home often because he's off fighting Napoleon. But when he is there, he lives in Morpeth outside newcastle he goes for walks over the hills takes bounce with him and wherever he goes he reaches into his pocket for some acorns and he plants them so that they will grow into oaks so that say in 2023 yeah britain will be able to chop down oaks and make great ships make. Oh, this is the moment. So Collingwood's oaks that he planted with Bounce are still standing, are they? Yes.
是的。当他在家时——他并不常在家，因为他一直在外与拿破仑作战。但当他在家时，他住在纽卡斯尔郊外的莫珀斯，他在群山上散步，带着Bounce一起去。无论走到哪里，他都会把手伸进口袋抓一把橡果，把它们种下去，这样它们就会长成橡树，以便比如说在2023年——是的，英国将能够砍伐橡树来建造伟大的船只。哦，就是现在。所以科林伍德和Bounce一起种下的橡树现在还在，是吗？是的。
Oh, splendid. You know, they're ready to be chopped down and turned into ships of the line right now. Great. Very good. So Bounce is with Collingwood when Collingwood goes over to HMS Victory, to Nelson's cabin to discuss the battle plans before Trafalgar. So Bounce is there. I mean, obviously, in the battle itself, he's below decks, shivering underneath a blanket. I mean, he probably doesn't contribute
哦，太棒了。你知道的，它们现在随时准备被砍伐并变成主力舰。太棒了。非常好。所以当科林伍德登上“胜利号”（HMS Victory）、前往纳尔逊的船舱讨论特拉法加战役前的作战计划时，Bounce也和科林伍德在一起。所以Bounce也在。我的意思是，显然在战斗本身中，它躲在甲板下面，瑟瑟发抖地躲在毯子底下。我的意思是，它可能并没有对讨论做出
much to the discussion, presumably. Well, I suppose he kind of... he probably provides inspiration to the British captains. An example of a British dog. Yeah, British pluck. The bulldog spirit. I mean, he's not a bulldog, but he could be a bulldog because we don't know what he is. I imagine he's not a French poodle. No, British pluck. The bulldog spirit. I mean, he's not a bulldog, but he could be a bulldog because we don't know what he is. I imagine he's not a French poodle.
太多贡献，大概吧。嗯，我想它大概……它大概为英国船长们提供了灵感。一只英国狗的榜样。是的，英国的坚毅。斗牛犬精神。我的意思是，它不是斗牛犬，但它可能是斗牛犬，因为我们不知道它是什么。我猜它不是一只法国卷毛狗。不，英国的坚毅。斗牛犬精神。我的意思是，它不是斗牛犬，但它可能是斗牛犬，因为我们不知道它是什么。我猜它不是一只法国卷毛狗。
No, definitely not. That would be very bad. Not some fancy Frenchified dandy dog. Well, although, Dominic, so after the Battle of Trafalgar, he becomes Baron Collingwood of Calderburn and Hethpool in the county of Northumberland, which means, of course, that Bounce has been elevated. Collingwood writes back to his family saying that he's all out of patience with Bounce. The consequential airs he gives himself since he became a right honourable dog are insufferable. He considers it beneath his dignity to play with commonest dogs and truly thinks that he does them grace when he cons to lift up his leg against them. So that's quite sad. Is Collingwood serious? No, it's naval banter, Dominic. Right, okay, just checking. Four years after Trafalgar, Bounce is getting very old.
不，绝对不是。那可太糟了。可不是什么花哨的法国化花花公子狗。不过，多米尼克，在特拉法加海战之后，他成为了诺森伯兰郡卡尔德本和海思普尔的科林伍德男爵，这意味着，当然，Bounce的身份也提升了。科林伍德写信给他的家人，说他对Bounce已经失去了耐心。“自从它成为一只受人尊敬的狗以来，它摆出的那些自命不凡的架势简直令人无法忍受。它认为和普通的狗玩耍有失自己的身份，并且真的认为当它屈尊向它们抬起一条腿时，是在赐予它们恩惠。”所以这挺让人难过的。科林伍德是认真的吗？不，这是海军式的玩笑，多米尼克。好吧，好的，只是确认一下。特拉法加海战四年后，Bounce已经很老了。
He's become rheumatic and he falls overboard and drowns. Oh, my God. You can't just come out with that, Tom, with no preparation. Well, so Collingwood was distraught and again wrote back and said what a huge loss Bounce was. I have few comforts but he was one for he loved me everybody sorrows for him he was wiser than many who hold their heads higher and was grateful to those who were kind to him this is one of our most poignant podcasts well it gets even more poignant because the crew on collingwood's ship yeah even though they couldn't
它患上了风湿病，失足落水淹死了。哦，天哪。你不能就这么说出来，汤姆，一点铺垫都没有。好吧，所以科林伍德心碎了，再次写信说Bounce的离去是多么巨大的损失。“我没有什么安慰，但它是其中之一，因为它爱我。所有人都为它悲哀。它比许多昂首挺胸的人更聪明，并且对那些对它好的人心存感激。”这是我们最令人心酸的播客之一。嗯，它甚至变得更加心酸，因为科林伍德船上的船员——是的，尽管他们不能
give bounce a proper naval burial because obviously he'd fallen overboard and drowned. They make a small coffin the size of the dog and they drape it in a Union Jack and then they give it a burial at sea. Good for them. That reflects very well on the Royal Navy. And they then pull into, they go to the Balearicas, they pull into Mallorca and the crew buy Collingwood a new Bounce.
给Bounce举行一场真正的海军葬礼，因为显然它落水淹死了。他们做了一个只有狗那么大的小棺材，在上面盖上一面英国国旗，然后为它举行了海葬。真棒。这为皇家海军增色不少。然后他们驶入巴利阿里群岛，停靠在马略卡岛，船员们给科林伍德买了一只新的Bounce。
They dress him as a sailor with an ex-scarf. An ex-scarf. He would apparently parade with the Marines. I don't want to alienate our American listeners, so I know we're very keen on this, but I don't really approve of dog in clothes. No, well. So dressing him as a sailor, I don't approve of. Yeah, I hear you.
他们把它打扮成水手模样，戴着一条围巾。一条围巾。它显然会和海军陆战队员一起列队游行。我不想疏远我们的美国听众，我知道我们非常热衷于此，但我其实不太赞成给狗穿衣服。不，好吧。所以把它打扮成水手，我是不赞成的。是的，我懂你的意思。
But the fact remains that Bounce 2 stayed on board ship even after Collingwood himself had died. Really? And so what happened to Bounce, the junior? I don't know. He just kind of looked like he became the ship dog. Okay. So that's a stirring and happy story, I think.
但事实仍然是，Bounce 2号即使在科林伍德本人去世后，仍然留在了船上。真的吗？那么Bounce二世后来怎么样了？我不知道。它好像就成了船上的吉祥物。好吧。所以这是一个感人且快乐的故事，我想。
That is a nice story. And you've got one more to go, Tom. So I still think Checkers is the best dog, but that's because I'm biased. But Bounce, I have to say, is right up there. It's very, very close. But could our final dog storm through to the title? I think you'd agree that all of these dogs would make great films yeah well in fact great fries bobby has
这是一个美好的故事。你还有一个要讲，汤姆。所以我仍然认为“查克斯”（Checkers）是最好的狗，但这只是因为我偏心。但我不得不说，Bounce绝对名列前茅。非常非常接近。但是我们最后一只狗能冲进冠军宝座吗？我想你会同意，所有这些狗都能拍成伟大的电影。是的，事实上，伟大的“忠犬巴比”
been a film but the final dog is a dog who was in loads of films as an actor um and that is rintin tin oh yeah very good choice who was again a german shepherd dog. An extraordinary story. So Rintintin is a German shepherd dog, but is born in France on the Western Front in 1918, as the Allies are kind of pushing forward and the Germans are starting to retreat. And during this great push, the Americans are rolling the German lines up. And a guy called Corporal Lee Duncan, who is in the US Army Air Service, is sent forward with a group of other men to secure a French village called Fleury to see if, that the Germans have fled. But there, there is a kennel. And in the kennel, there is a German shepherd and she has just given birth to a litter of five tiny puppies. And they're so small that they haven't even opened their eyes yet. Duncan rescues the dogs, the mother and the puppies, and he brings them back to his unit. And he gives away all the dogs, including the mother and the puppies, and he brings them back to his unit. And he gives away all the dogs, including the mother and the puppies, but he keeps two, a boy and a girl.
已经拍成电影了。但最后一只狗是一只在大量电影中担任演员的狗——那就是丁丁历险记里的丁丁（Rintintin）。哦，对，非常好的选择。它也是一只德国牧羊犬。一段非凡的故事。所以丁丁是一只德国牧羊犬，但它于1918年生于法国西线，当时盟军正在向前推进，德军开始撤退。在这场大推进中，美军正在瓦解德军的防线。一个名叫李·邓肯（Lee Duncan）下士的人——他在美国陆军航空勤务队服役——被派往前方，与一队人一起去确保一个名为弗勒里（Fleury）的法国村庄的安全，看看德军是否已经逃跑。但在那里，有一个狗舍。在狗舍里，有一只德国牧羊犬，它刚刚生下一窝五只小狗。它们太小了，甚至连眼睛都还没睁开。邓肯救了这些狗，狗妈妈和几只小狗，把它们带回了他的部队。他送走了所有的狗，包括狗妈妈和几只小狗，但留下了两只，一公一母。
And he calls the boy Rin Tin Tin, and he calls the girl Nanette. Actually, Rin Tin Tin is probably Ran Tan Tan, actually, because these were good luck charms that were given to American soldiers by children in Franceance so ran tan tan and lanette i did not know yeah oh han tan tan would not have been a name for a film star no so rintin tin he becomes because duncan smuggles the two puppies aboard the troop ship when they go back in 1919 i suppose they're not puppies by then are they they're no kind of whatever adolescent frisky adolescent dogs frisky adolescent i mean must be tricky to keep them on the troop ship anyway he gets him he smuggles them across um they get to
他给公的取名叫Rin Tin Tin，给母的取名叫Nanette。事实上，Rin Tin Tin其实可能是Ran Tan Tan，因为这些是法国儿童送给美国士兵的幸运符。所以是 Ran Tan Tan 和 Lanette。我不知道啊。哦，Han Tan Tan可不会是一个电影明星的名字。所以Rin Tin Tin，当邓肯在1919年他们返回时把这两只小狗偷运上运兵船时——我猜那时它们已经不是小狗了吧？它们是那种……无论如何，是处于青春期、精力旺盛的青春期小狗。精力旺盛的青春期——我的意思是，在运兵船上管住它们一定很棘手。无论如何，他把它弄上去了，他把它偷运过去。它们到了
america nanette very sadly i think dies in new york i think he gets quarantined and dies and so duncan buys another dog nanette too it's a bit like we've had bounce too we have nanette too he comes from California, from Los Angeles, and he takes Rin Tin Tin and Nanette with him back to LA. And when he gets to LA, he teaches Rin Tin Tin all kinds of tricks. And the particular thing that Rin Tin Tin can do is to jump enormous heights. And this obviously in LA, in Hollywood, where producers are always looking for kind of exciting stunts and things that they can put into the movies, this becomes something that attracts
美国，Nanette非常遗憾地在纽约死了，我想它被隔离然后死了。所以邓肯买了一只新狗Nanette 2号。这有点像我们刚才有Bounce 2号，我们也有Nanette 2号。他来自加利福尼亚，洛杉矶，他带着Rin Tin Tin和Nanette回到了洛杉矶。当他到达洛杉矶时，他教Rin Tin Tin各种各样的把戏。Rin Tin Tin尤其擅长的一点是跳跃惊人的高度。这在洛杉矶、在好莱坞显而易见——那里的制片人总是在寻找令人兴奋的特技和可以放进电影里的东西——这成了吸引
the casting directors. And so in 1922, Rin Tin Tin is actually cast as a wolf in a film called The Man from Hell's River. And he plays the wolf tremendously well. So much so that the following year in 1923, he gets his first lead and he appears in 27 movies in all. He is such a star that he comes to be called the mortgage lifter by people in Hollywood. Because he makes films that enables people to pay off their mortgages.
选角导演的东西。所以在1922年，Rin Tin Tin实际上在一部名为《来自地狱之河的男人》（The Man from Hell's River）的电影中扮演了一只狼。它把这只狼演得极其出色。以至于第二年，即1923年，它迎来了它的第一个主角，它总共出演了27部电影。它是个如此耀眼的明星，以至于被好莱坞的人们称为“抵押贷款偿还者”。因为它拍的电影能让人还清抵押贷款。
That's a good name. And actually, the guy whose career really gets a lift from Rin Tin Tin is Daryl F. Zanuck, who is the guy who goes on to become the head of 20th Century Fox. So he starts his career as a screenwriter and he writes- For Rin Tin Tin? Yeah, he writes screenplays for Rin Tin Tin. And the story is that in 1929, when they have the first Oscars ceremonyplays for Rin Tin Tin. And the story is that in 1929, when they have the first Oscars ceremony, that Rin Tin Tin is actually,
这名字真不错。事实上，真正因为Rin Tin Tin而事业起飞的人是达尔F·扎纳克（Daryl F. Zanuck），也就是后来成为20世纪福克斯公司负责人的人。所以他以编剧身份开始职业生涯，他写——为Rin Tin Tin写的？是的，他为Rin Tin Tin写剧本。传闻在1929年举办第一届奥斯卡颁奖典礼时，Rin Tin Tin实际上，
he gets voted best actor. And the organisers of the Oscars are not going to have that. And so he gets disqualified. I think that's actually an urban myth. That sounds utterly implausible. That's great for us Bobby standards of veracity. Gellert.
它被投票选为最佳男主角。而奥斯卡的主办方可不能容忍这一点。于是它被取消了资格。我认为这其实是一个都市传说。听起来完全不可信。这简直符合我们对“忠犬巴比”的真实性标准。格莱特。
Meanwhile, Rin Tin Tin, he's a Hollywood star, so he's That's great for us, Bobby. Standards of veracity. Gellert. Yeah. Meanwhile, Rin Tin Tin, you know, he's a Hollywood star. So he's having a great time with Nanette, hanging out with Nanette. So hold on, Nanette's not his sister. This isn't a Ptolemy style arrangement. There's a slight Ptolemaic vibe there because she's a replacement for the sister. Okay. But that's quite Hollywood, isn't it? I mean, it's quite Hollywood.
与此同时，Rin Tin Tin，它是个好莱坞明星，所以它——这简直符合我们对“忠犬巴比”的真实性标准。格莱特。是的。与此同时，Rin Tin Tin，你知道的，它是个好莱坞明星。所以它和Nanette过得很开心，经常和Nanette厮混在一起。等等，Nanette不是它的姐姐吗？这不是托勒密式的安排吧？这里确实有点托勒密王朝的味道，因为它是他姐姐的替代品。好吧。但这很“好莱坞”，不是吗？我的意思是，这相当好莱坞。
I suppose so. So they have 48 puppies. 48? Yeah. But how many would you have in one go? I'm not familiar with... I don't know. Dog biology is, you know, a mystery to me. They're obviously very fond of each other. They're having a lot of fun by the pool,
我想是的。所以它们生了48只小狗。48只？是的。但你一次能生多少只？我不熟悉……我不知道。狗狗的生物学对我来说是个谜。它们显然彼此非常喜欢。它们在泳池边玩得很开心，
hanging out, keeping his Oscar. And then he dies in August 1932. And weirdly, his body is sent back to France. That is kind of strange. It's buried in a pet cemetery outside Paris. Oh yeah, the Cimetière des Chiens et Autres Animaux Domestiques. Yeah, they're very same. I wonder what else is buried in that. I don't know.
厮混在一起，守护着他的奥斯卡奖。然后它于1932年8月去世。奇怪的是，它的遗体被送回了法国。这有点奇怪。它被埋在巴黎郊外的一个宠物墓地里。哦，对，巴黎宠物及其他动物公墓。是的，它们是同一个。我想知道那里还埋了什么别的。我不知道。
If we have any listeners who know who else, what other famous animals might be buried in that. But Rin Tin Tin was unbelievably famous. So Anne Frank, in her diary, actually the second entry in her diary, writes of saying that she longed to have a dog like Rin Tin Tin. The thing about Rin Tin Tin is that he's very energetic. He's an outdoors dog. He's jumping off walls and doing stunts and things like that. And it's so sad that Anne Frank is, I mean, that's kind of the pathos of it.
如果我们有任何听众知道那里还埋了谁、可能还埋了什么其他著名的动物。但Rin Tin Tin曾经红得难以置信。所以安妮·弗兰克在她的日记中——实际上是她日记的第二篇——写道，她渴望拥有一只像Rin Tin Tin一样的狗。Rin Tin Tin的特点是它精力非常充沛。它是一只户外活动的狗。它从墙上跳下来，做特技等等。真令人难过，安妮·弗兰克被关在——我的意思是，这就是悲凉之处。
Yeah. That she's locked up and pining for a dog. Pining for a dog. Rin Tin Tin obviously predates lassie i mean lassie was the cinematic dog that i was most familiar with growing up rintintin is the trailblazer yeah lassie's a pale shadow of rintintin i suppose i don't know i mean it's being too harsh to lassie no i think you're a bit harsh to lassie if i was ranking visual dogs i'd put canine first and then r Tin Tin and then Lassie.
是的。她被关起来，渴望有一只狗。渴望有一只狗。Rin Tin Tin显然比莱西（Lassie）出现得更早。我的意思是，莱西是我在成长过程中最熟悉的电影里的狗，而Rin Tin Tin是开路先锋。是的，莱西只是Rin Tin Tin的苍白影子，我想。我不知道，我的意思是，对莱西是不是太严厉了？不，我觉得你对莱西有点太严厉了。如果要我按视觉形象给狗排位，我会把卡恩（K-9）排在第一位，然后是Rin Tin Tin，然后是莱西。
I like a robot dog. Yeah, I hear you. I don't know whether Lassie has a star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame because Rin Tin Tin does. Really? Do you want to do some live research? Sure. And see whether Lassie's got one.
我喜欢机器人狗。是的，我懂你的意思。我不知道莱西在好莱坞星光大道上有没有一颗星星，因为Rin Tin Tin有。真的吗？你想做点现场搜索吗？当然。看看莱西有没有。
I bet, I mean, canine wouldn't have one. So canine, we should explain for non-British listeners who are not very old, was Tom Baker's dog in Doctor Who. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So it was tom baker's dog in doctor who yeah yeah yeah so it was a mechanized dog it's a bit like r2d2 only it looked like a dog so tom i have a great fact for you i've done my life research yeah not on wikipedia as some very cruel people sometimes allege about this podcast but on the los angeles times so i've gone straight to the source yeah and what was it saying there are three dogs on the Hollywood Walk of Fame. Okay.
我敢打赌——我的意思是，卡恩不会有的。所以卡恩，我们应该为那些不太老、非英国听众解释一下，它是《神秘博士》中汤姆·贝克（Tom Baker）的狗。是的，是的，是的。所以它是《神秘博士》中汤姆·贝克的狗。是的，是的，是的。所以它是一只机械狗，有点像R2-D2，只是长得像狗。所以，汤姆，我有一个很棒的事实要告诉你。我已经做了现场研究。是的，不是在维基百科上——正如一些非常残忍的人有时对这个播客的指控那样——而是在《洛杉矶时报》上。所以我直接找到了源头。是的，那上面怎么说？星光大道上有三只狗。好吧。
So Rintintin, I'm guessing Lassie. So they're Lassie, Rintintin, and Strongheart. Now, do you know who Strongheart is? No, never heard of Strongheart. Strongheart was also a veteran of the First World War. Strongheart served with the German Red Cross in World War I. And in those days, actually, it had a very distinguished name. Strongheart was known as Etzel von Oeringen. Goodness. But actually had a very distinguished name. Strongheart was
所以Rin Tin Tin，我猜有莱西。所以它们是莱西、Rin Tin Tin和强心（Strongheart）。现在，你知道强心是谁吗？不，从没听说过强心。强心也是第一次世界大战的老兵。强心在一战中随德国红十字会服役。在那时，实际上，它有一个非常显赫的名字。强心被称为埃策尔·冯·厄林根（Etzel von Oeringen）。天哪。但实际上有一个非常显赫的名字。强心被
known as Etzel von Oeringen. Goodness. But I don't know anything else about Strongheart. What did Strongheart do? What were the films? Well, I'm going to do some more live research. Here we are. Now I am on Wikipedia. Etzel von Oeringen, better known as Strongheart, 1917 to 1929, was a male, another German shepherd, third in his class at the Shepherd Dog Club of America, 1920, was trained as a police dog in Berlin, served in the Red Cross, sold to America, and then appears in one, two, three, four, six films. Well, that's not very impressive compared to Rin Tin Tin's 27.
称为埃策尔·冯·厄林根。天哪。但我对强心一无所知。强心做了什么？有哪些电影？好吧，我要做更多现场研究。这里。现在我在维基百科上。埃策尔·冯·厄林根，更为人所知的名字是强心，1917年至1929年，是一只雄性——又是一只德国牧羊犬，1920年美国牧羊犬俱乐部品种赛同类中排名第三，在柏林被训练为警犬，在红十字会服役，被卖到美国，然后出演了一部、两部、三部、四部、六部电影。好吧，跟Rin Tin Tin的27部比起来，这可不怎么impressive（令人印象深刻）。
Yeah, but makes his debut, Tom, before Rin Tin Tin. So 1921, The Silent Call. So he is Cliff Richard to Rin Tin Tin's Beatles. Very much so. Edsel van Oeringen, I call him by his real name, immense in body and hind leg formation, in body and legs better than either of the dogs above him. This is at the dog show. So a very impressive dog, Tom.
是的，但是汤姆，它的出道比Rin Tin Tin更早。所以是1921年的《无声的呼唤》（The Silent Call）。所以它之于Rin Tin Tin，就像克里夫·理查德（Cliff Richard）之于披头士乐队。确实如此。埃策尔·冯·厄林根——我用它的真名称呼它——身体和后腿结构极为出色，身材和腿部都比它上面的两只狗还要好。这是在狗展上。所以这是一只非常令人印象深刻的狗，汤姆。
Did he ever appear with rintintin no imagine that born in wrocław in germany uh later in poland died in los angeles his body was not returned to europe unlike rintintin but he was the subject of a book called strong heart the story of a wonder dog it's interesting though isn't it because i mean it's a bit like charlie chaplin or boris karloff europeans going over and becoming big, big Hollywood stars. They're both the dogs. We should have adopted that as the theme of this podcast. We should have narrowed it down and had a more focused podcast on emigre dogs in Hollywood in the 1920s.
它和Rin Tin Tin一起出现过吗？没有。想象一下，生于德国弗罗茨瓦夫——后来属于波兰，死于洛杉矶。它的遗体没有像Rin Tin Tin那样被运回欧洲，但它是《强心：一只奇迹狗的故事》（Strongheart: The Story of a Wonder Dog）一书的主角。不过这很有趣，不是吗？因为——我的意思是，这有点像查理·卓别林或鲍里斯·卡洛夫，欧洲人去到那里并成为了超级好莱坞巨星。这两只都是狗。我们本该把这作为这个播客的主题。我们本可以缩小范围，做一个更聚焦于20世纪20年代好莱坞的移民狗狗的播客。
I strongly disagree. I think that all seven of these dogs have been splendid. And so I mentioned that Laker. Yeah, we're going to do another on that we are also going to do another dog dominic who didn't appear and i'm surprised you didn't pick me up on that and that is boy who was the dog owned by prince rupert who had necromantic powers could catch bullets in his mouth yes am i right yes but his necromantic powers were inadequate against oliver cromwell's iron signs the battle of marston moore and the reason that i left boy off is that i'm sure we'll be talking about him when we do our special on the English Civil War, which we will be doing. 12 part epic.
我强烈反对。我认为这全部七只狗都表现得极为出色。所以我提到过雷克（Laker）。是的，我们还会做另一期关于——我们还将做另一只狗，多米尼克，它没有出现，我很惊讶你没有挑出这一点——那就是“男孩”（Boy），鲁珀特亲王（Prince Rupert）拥有的那只狗，它拥有通灵能力，能在嘴里接住子弹。是的，我说得对吗？是的，但它的通灵能力在奥利弗·克伦威尔（Oliver Cromwell）的铁骑面前无济于事，马斯顿荒原战役。我把“男孩”落下的原因是我确信我们在做关于英国内战的专题时会谈到它，而我们一定会做的。12集史诗。
Yeah, one day. So, Tom, if you could choose one dog of these dogs, which do you choose? Oh, I think Bounce. Really? Yeah. You like a naval dog? Yeah. And a patriotic dog?
是的，总有一天。所以，汤姆，如果你能从这些狗中选择一只，你会选哪只？哦，我想选Bounce。真的吗？是的。你喜欢海军犬？是的。还有爱国犬？
I like a patriotic dog. Part of me would actually love to have a dog called Looty. I know that presents me in a very bad light. It does present you in a very bad light. And I can imagine, Dominic, that were some of your critics to be listening to that, they would not be surprised. But of course, they won't be listening to this. They'd rather boil their heads.
我喜欢爱国犬。其实我内心深处很想养一只名叫鲁蒂（Looty）的狗。我知道这让我看起来很糟糕。这确实让你看起来很糟糕。而且我能想象到，多米尼克，如果你的某些批评者听到这里，他们不会感到惊讶。但当然，他们不会听这个。他们宁愿把头煮了。
All right. Well, that was a splendid, what is it? A kind of gamble through. Yes, a walk. We've taken you for a walk through history's greatest dogs. So what will we be back with next week? I don't think we will be in the animal kingdom, will we? We will be back with the fall of Saigon.
好吧。那真是一场精彩的——怎么说呢？一次随意的漫游。是的，散步。我们带你漫步走过了历史上最伟大的那些狗狗。那么我们下周会带着什么回归呢？我想我们不会再身处动物王国了吧？我们将带着西贡的陷落回归。
Crikey. So no, less of the canine theme banter and more of the, oh my God, we should warn people right now. You do your Marlon Brando impersonation in that series, don't you? Yes, I do. The single most remarkable impersonation. It's very kind. I'm using that phrase very advisedly that you've ever done in the history of The Rest
天哪。所以，不，少一些犬科主题的玩笑，多一些——哦，天哪，我们现在就应该警告大家。你在那个系列里模仿了马龙·白兰度（Marlon Brando），对吧？是的，我模仿了。那是有史以来最了不起的模仿。我是经过深思熟虑才用这个词的——这是你在《其余皆历史》的历史上做过的最了不起的模仿。
Is History. Thank you. Even more remarkable than Marilyn Monroe, you think? Even more remarkable than Marilyn Monroe. So it's a two-parter. Thank you. Even more remarkable than Marilyn Monroe, you think? Even more remarkable than Marilyn Monroe. So it's a two-parter. It's on the fall of Saigon, and it's on the Vietnam Syndrome and the legacy of the end of the Vietnam War in 70s America. So that's something to look forward to.
谢谢你。你觉得甚至比玛丽莲·梦露（Marilyn Monroe）还要了不起？甚至比玛丽莲·梦露还要了不起。所以这是一个两集专题。谢谢你。甚至比玛丽莲·梦露还要了不起，你觉得？甚至比玛丽莲·梦露还要了不起。所以这是一个两集专题。讲的是西贡的陷落，讲的是越战综合征以及70年代美国越战结束的遗产。所以这绝对值得期待。
Lots of treats to come after that. Tom, that was a tour de force. Thank you. Thank you very much for that, and we'll see you next time. Goodbye. Bye-bye. thank you very much for that and we'll see you next time goodbye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
后面还有很多精彩内容。汤姆，这是一次精彩绝伦的演讲。谢谢你。非常感谢你，我们下次再见。再见。拜拜。非常感谢你，我们下次再见，再见，感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。想要获取独家节目、提前收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许的娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及优先购买现场门票的权利，请前往……本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。